we've got interesting news coming out of
Twitter
we heard that Marjorie Taylor green Andy
know the post millennial and many others
had been suspended for calling out
what's called the trans day of Vengeance
well as it turns out Twitter is actually
stating they're banning anyone promoting
it and because they had to manually go
through and remove all of these some
people got mixed up with those who are
actually promoting it when they were
calling it out this is the problem with
social media censorship it's been the
problem the whole time you catch
everyone regardless of context and uh
well we can't function that way but the
big story here is the active calls for a
day of Vengeance considering what
happened just the other day it is rather
shocking that there are still people
online actively calling for more in fact
some advocacy groups are telling people
to take up arms and get prepared they're
they're using this as a rallying cry
so we'll get into all of that and we'll
talk about it but for those that are
wondering about yesterday's episode
yesterday's episode is fully available
on our Rumble page at Rumble that I
think it's what rumble.com timcastirl
yeah it's it's there it's if you're
wondering where the show went it's there
and for people wondering why we're not
on Rumble uh that episode is as well as
many other episodes that um you know for
um
for the sake of clarity I suppose I can
only tell you to watch that episode its
entirety and you'll understand why it's
on Rumble instead of YouTube Because of
You YouTube's rules we are not going to
be able to explain it on YouTube hence
the problem but it is explained on
Rumble so before we get started today we
have an awesome sponsor public
square.com that's publicsq.com it's a
mobile app that shows you businesses
that support American values right now
the most important thing we can do is
help build that parallel economy and
make sure you're not giving money to
people who hate you you've heard the
daily wire talk about it don't give
money to people who hate you give to
them instead well Public Square gives
you a list of all of these businesses
that have taken a pledge to support Free
Speech American value traditional family
things of that nature these are
businesses that deserve your support and
if you download the Public Square app or
go to publicesq.com you can be a part of
this we've had the founders on the show
before they're amazing I think it's a
fantastic app it's a brilliant idea
and with the help of them of Public
Square we are going to win this culture
War so support these businesses check it
out and I also have more very big news
ladies and gentlemen cast brew coffee is
now available for pre-order I know I
know pre-order they're not going to ship
until May 5th but there's a good reason
it's because when you put the order in
We Begin the roast fresh just for you
that's right we are going to once the
order comes in everything begins that's
when the process officially kicks off
and so
um the official Ship by date would be
May 5th if you order today at
castbrew.com we have uh four different
available roasts my personal favorite
rise with Roberto Jr breakfast blend
it's a light roast and then we have
Appalachian nights which is a very dark
roast it's a robust dark blend not quite
as dark as espresso but darker than
French and then we also have a Colombian
medium and we have an apple I'm sorry
and then we have the French roast which
is right up here which is a little a
little bit more dark I'm actually
thinking I'm gonna I'm gonna start
drinking out of the light roast with the
rise of Roberto Jr just because Roberto
Jr is a superstar and he's my favorite
so I'm going to go with uh his his blend
that is castbrew.com hopefully within
the end of the next month we will have
whole right now it's all ground coffee
but then we'll have whole bean as well
ground is just the easiest to launch
most people don't have coffee grinders
so we're just selling ground bags of
ground coffee and then we got a bunch
more in the mix a bunch more different
blends and things that we like that
you're going to really enjoy but it is
officially up and the physical location
is currently underway and it could be as
soon as two months the location will be
in West Virginia so really excited for
that also don't forget to become a
member at timcast.com by clicking the
join us button when you become a member
at timcast.com you'll get access to our
Discord server where you will get a
chance to submit questions and call into
our uncensored after show so at about 10
10 pm we will be live with an uncensored
live portion of the show which will be
available on the front page of the
website and we'll even take some guest
questions call-ins from you guys who are
members so sign up support us but very
important distinction if you are not a
member currently and you want to to get
into the call-in section then you have
to do the 25 a month membership I
explained this before but for those that
don't know wait to create some kind of
gate to keep out weirdos and harassment
and activists so if you're a member at
10 bucks for at least six months you
instantly get access to the VIP chat
room otherwise it's 25 bucks so we can
create some kind of gatekeeping to keep
out bad people and Bad actors I wish it
wasn't that way but that's the way we
have to do it because we have had bad
actors come in try and get us banned
with that being said don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and joining us tonight to talk
about this and so much more is the
lovely Kimberly Guilfoyle hi uh we're
good to be here this is very cool we're
excited to have you yeah it's nice to be
here in person versus just watching it
online and it's like the whole thing
coming together I feel like I'm in The
Matrix right now I'm just gonna go with
that all right well for those that
aren't aren't familiar who are you and
what do you do who am I right that's a
really good uh existential question uh
so Kimberly Guilfoyle and you probably
well some of you may have or if not
whatever I'm from television I'm a
former prosecutor and then went to New
York and signed with a bunch of networks
I was on ABC News Good Morning America
exclusive to them in the morning core TV
myancho covering all the big legal cases
because I'm a former prosecutor from San
Francisco in Los Angeles District
Attorney's office and then exclusive to
CNN at night with Anderson Cooper and
Larry King before CNN went totally woke
and broke and then went over to Fox News
and I served there amazingly for like 12
years helped launch the five outnumbered
uh 10 New Year's Eve shows I have post
that I've hosted everything from Fox and
Friends to all the prime time shows as
well and then served as senior advisor
to the 45th president of the United
States and also the National Finance
chair for the 2020 election wow that's a
lot um and a former special education
teacher and a former model I I like jobs
I think we'll we'll need to get into
this point at which the culture split
completely and you're mentioning being
at CNN before they got woke and went
broke yeah so I'll be interested we
should definitely talk about the later
in the show that point at which the
split started to occur and when you
started to see it because you're
actively working in these media
companies when it's it's fascinating to
be in those newsrooms and to be in those
management meetings and discussions and
just you know discussing the editorial
what's going to be in the rundown of the
shows what are we going to cover what
are we not going to cover it's very
interesting to see how this just evolved
over time and I had to ask Steve cracker
on my show who did a book called um
recently called uncovered and talked all
about what was going on in the newsrooms
he had worked at CNN as well and just
sort of the metamorphosis covering
everything between covid and the
pandemics the 2016 election the 2020
election and how that all has really
just shaped what we've seen from my
corporate media right on this will be
fun so thanks for hanging out we also
got Brett dasovic from pop culture
crisis hanging out what is going on guys
yes I do host pop culture crisis my
resume is not quite that long but uh
Monday through Friday at 3 P.M we do
discuss pop culture movies and
television Hollywood and a lot of times
that is unfortunately where Hollywood
politics and culture all seem to
intersect so it does kind of cross over
into the sphere happy to be here right
on hi everyone Ian Crossland here and
thank you for making noise about the
restrict act this nonsense act that the
house of uh House of Representatives was
put into the Senate so I've seen a lot
of noise about it it is the Patriot Act
of Technology we need to shut it down
now before it gets out of hand thank you
and let's keep this moving we also have
search dupreya yes I am surge.com
pleasure to see you guys uh let's start
the show shall we here's the first story
we have from the post millennial
breaking and you know the
post-millennial prominent conservatives
locked out of Twitter after reporting on
trans day of Vengeance they have this
image here it says remove tweet
violating our rules against violent
speech you may not share abusive content
harass someone or encourage other people
to do so this is a post from the
post-millennial on Twitter that said
radical trans activists and a DC antifa
Group are organizing a trans day of
Vengeance protest and they've blurred
the day and the location because Twitter
is cracking down now I saw initial
reporting that Marjorie Taylor green had
been suspended for calling it out and
the initial assumption was that people
were who were reporting on this and
criticizing it were getting suspended
they were but what Twitter claims to
have been trying to do I think I might
have the Tweet uh here
this is Ella Irwin responding to Ian
miles Chong saying uh Ian Mouse Chong
tweets Twitter is now cracking down on
those who promote the trans day of
Vengeance poster which mostly comprises
of trans militants who are calling for a
day of mass violence do not share the
poster or you could be caught up in the
bands to prevent Mass violence from
happening Ella Irwin responds correct
we had to automatically sweep our
platform and remove more than 5 000
tweets and retweets of this poster we do
not support tweets that incite violence
irrespective of who post them Vengeance
does not imply peaceful protest
organizing a supportive peaceful protest
is okay
this is fascinating this is absolutely
fascinating because for one we're still
seeing a problem of contextless
censorship you know criticizing this is
not same as promoting it but the
automated censorship can't track that
but more importantly when I went on
Rogan's show all those years ago with
Dorsey and vegetate I specifically
highlighted leftist violence incitement
Advance was being allowed on the
platform meanwhile people on the right
were being banned now Twitter is
actually cracking down and removing
left-wing calls for extreme violence I
wonder if this is an inflection point
yeah it's really interesting fascinating
to see how this has evolved and and
who's to credit for it you know Elon
Musk I guess or some of the new teams
that are in there trying to crack down
but it's interesting because we see
people like MTG
um Andy no they're hitting them but only
because they put it out there to
highlight it that this is improper to
call for Trans Vengeance and violence
like this which is you should have a
right to be able to call it out and say
this isn't proper this is dangerous it
doesn't you know belong here in you know
in society but that then they try to go
back and say no no no no no we just
don't want anything suggesting violence
not even anyone criticizing the people
who are calling for violence I'm not mad
at Twitter about this one though I they
corrected it yeah they've restored the
accounts they did an automatic sweep I
I'm actually curious Ian's perspective
because you you moderated for mines yeah
so I'm wondering I mean if you're
watching far left extremists or forward
extremists for that matter
thousands of accounts promoting a day of
mass violence what do you do I think
they did the right thing too because
it's like if someone posts child
pornography on Twitter and then other
people like retweeting it and saying
look how gross this is you're still
complicit in proliferating child porn at
that point so I understand what they did
they had to they had to rip out the
roots and if you were hanging on the
tree branches you're gonna fall down
when that tree comes out well they did
the right thing by reinstating the
accounts right I agree it's a little
it's a little bit more than I would say
I'd say you should be allowed to report
on it you should be as a reporter
allowed to share this and say look what
they're calling for you need to know
this because if you live in DC I think
it's very important you see who and what
uh who's sharing it and what's being
shared it's a constant struggle in the
administrationship of social medias how
do you report on images and imagery that
violates
the terms because you can't show it
you're violating the terms if you show
them you can but you're violating the
terms to show it
um you can blur it out but they're not
really showing it so no one knows what
you're reporting on right but then is
that censorship it's definitely a form
of censorship well not that's the
quandary not all censorship is bad
okay yeah uh if someone posts like like
Ian mentioned child porn you want
sensors to catch that and get rid of it
and then refer it to the police yeah
well that's a crime right exactly and so
the problem is what we often end up
seeing from these big social platforms
is protection for left-wing extremist
ideology
and then they ban a conservative saying
learn to code now my attitude here is
okay well it sucks that Andy Marjorie
TPM and others got suspended Twitter did
reinstate it but my view is if all of
these for Lift extremists are calling
for and what is it it's this Saturday
they were calling for a weekend Mass
violent wave considering what just
happened the other day with that trans
Mass shooter yeah Twitter's like we
gotta get this off the platform now so
it's a challenge of
if you're reporting on it you shouldn't
get censored for reporting on it but if
you get caught up in a mass sweep to
eliminate extremism and then get
reinstated
it's it's unfortunate I'm not going to
cry about it it's kind of like a
reporter standing on the side of the
street while there's a riot and they're
recording the cops are like get out of
here and they grab the reporter with
everyone else they arrest the reporter
then they let him go like that's
actually a fair point like drug sweeps
when people get pulled up for uh in
police raids and then some people are
there who aren't actually there legally
committing any crimes and then hopefully
if done properly they're released upon
finding out that they're not actually
guilty of anything whether that's
possession of some type of substance or
a weapon or anything like that so it
feels more like something like that also
I did want to ask is this connected
directly to the the image that they're
posting or is it keyword search with uh
hashtags I think it's the image okay and
I but I will stress this as much as look
I don't want anybody who's calling this
out and criticizing it to get suspended
this is suspension should not be the
image it should be the call for it for
the action and so Marjorie Taylor green
has two tweets we can see right here the
Tweet violated the Twitter rules they're
both removed they shouldn't be and it
looks like she got a third one that was
removed as well four it looks like there
are four tweets that have been removed
probably because she was saying hey this
is bad they should be restored you
should be allowed to share the image
it's then call for violence well it's
like you she's trying to call out
something that is a call for violence
that can be but you know potential like
criminal conduct and that also in my
opinion presents an issue and a real
threat to Public Safety so when you
think about it I would want to know if
I'm living in that area that there's
going to be this trans Vengeance
situation call for violence no offense
as a public safety issue if I'm going
down the street if I'm going somewhere I
want to know what's actually going on
and be alerted to it in my community
that's the other problem I have it just
with my background and understanding how
these things happen someone could be
walking into that they don't know what's
going on I would want to be it's almost
like a virtual or social media community
policing where their people are putting
it out there hey FYI look out for this
this is what's going to happen in the
neighborhood you should be aware of
what's happening in your community I
don't want to have like you know a mask
over my eyes cover my eyes cover my ears
and not know what's going on around me I
actually do want to be informed so
there's that as well with getting the
message out I know you have to think
about that you're a prosecutor yes how
would you handle people I mean there's
thousands of people posting this call
for violence I mean what would you do
yeah I mean I think it's a real problem
the call for violence but since it's
actually an event that is going to take
place then you also I believe have a
responsibility to let people know and to
be aware of it and then if you're a
prosecutor in law enforcement Etc you
want to try to control the situation
mitigate the damage the threat to Public
Safety the mitigate the threat of
personal injury or harm to people of
Riots of creating an unsafe situation
which we have seen happen over and over
again with the call for situations like
this whether it's Ferguson or you know
with the hands up don't shoot which then
turned out to not have you know happened
but they said what was important to call
this out I'm telling you it goes on from
here and there and then this is the same
situation but people want to be a little
bit more sensitive to it because it
involves you know trans issues like no I
don't care who you are how you identify
who you sleep with you know you don't
have a right to commit violence that
hinders the community and causes harm to
other human beings that is not a right
that you have so here's the challenge
the poster doesn't explicitly call for
violence it calls for vengeance right
well it's got enough buzzwords for
people to figure it out do you think you
could or should prosecute someone for
creating this and calling for this and
posting on the internet no but that's
criminal versus civilly so it put it
this way if it's something where there's
like a threat of violence we call them
terrorist threats but that's just the
the name on the penal code for a lot of
this which is if you threaten the life
of somebody and say you know I'm gonna
do this or that'll cause you know harm
to someone
um and you threaten them you're not
allowed to do that okay and that can
rise to the level of a felony but so but
this will say well this is just you know
a poster calling for people to meet
peacefully that's how they'll they'll
sugarcoat it however the people behind
it if ultimately that event takes place
and someone does get injured or harmed
then you're looking at a civil Forum
where someone can come in and Sue the
people who through the event Etc which
by the way we saw with January 6 right
so okay how did that start who's through
it people went who was injured lawsuits
ensued and it's in the courts a lot of
it right now
even using language like Vengeance it's
isn't that just neo-marx's Behavior
right to just use vague language which
they can manipulate at any time that
they want to mean whatever they want
because it's vague and it doesn't
actually have any type of implement uh
like implication to it but we know what
it means well we know what it means
because there's rifles on the picture
next to the word Vengeance I mean even
that like but that would come up in
court and it's the image that we're
talking about especially with the image
just following what happened in
Nashville yeah with these these these
poor children and these faculty members
yeah there is a clear understanding of
what that poster means there's a context
there's context out in the news in the
media socially Etc so people put it
together well here's the crazy thing is
that trans advocacy groups are still
pushing they're saying Get Ready they're
telling people to take up guns and
prepare for a fight after everything
that just happened it's so insane to me
that you would think that in because in
order to stop the government from
harming children you're going to hurt
children like that's what this girl did
yes there it is she she shot up six six
people three kids three nine-year-olds
because she was afraid that the
government was I don't know I don't know
her intentions actually I've seen text
of she said she was suicidal could be
fake text I don't know I don't know how
many hormones and drugs dming her friend
and Etc yeah but that you think that
killing people is gonna solve is gonna
protect you from the government killing
people it doesn't that's that's that's
not what they're saying though there
this is an ideological battle they they
are looking at they look at the rhetoric
around Christians and what they think of
Christians and it's and it's kind of
clear why this person did this and it's
scary but let me pull up this next story
we have from the post millennial
the post-millennial reports quote hate
has consequences trans group Mourns
death of Nashville trans Mass killer the
second and more complex tragedy is that
Aiden or Aubry Hale who felt he had no
other effective way to be seen than to
lash out by taking the life of others
this tweet says prepare to defend
yourself this weekend has already
provided us two Crystal Clear reasons
why we need to be prepared to defend
ourselves at a moment's notice against
Nazis and fascists
I don't want to read too much more into
this for obvious reasons because we're
talking about the lengths they're going
to advocate for more violence but that
post outright said this weekend get
ready and they're calling it defending
yourself this is what they do
the far left extremists go around
smashing windows and throwing fire bombs
and then when the police try to arrest
them they say they're allowed to defend
themselves they call the torching of
buildings and the beating of people in
the streets self-defense that's what
they're doing now with this I'm worried
about what's going to happen this
weekend so I would only say if you are
in the DC area exactly you need to be be
extra careful be prepared I don't know
I'm not going to give any advice me
personally if I was in DC I'd got it for
the weekend yeah no kidding but why not
you know Aaron the side of caution but
I'm going to tell you something this to
me the parallels are just it's
unbelievable if you look at the
juxtaposition just in between you know a
BLM and the whole the
Justified right to violence that they
assume and mischaracterize as
self-defense it's BLM it's antifa it's
all the same nonsense and they hide
behind their rhetoric and their rights
that they say that they have against
everyone else that they are allowed to
engage in violence that they are allowed
to loot to shoot to harm to injure to
destroy communities destroy property and
it's out of control and it's got to stop
and this is just another manifestation
of those movements now being expressed
in the trans movement you know another
manifestation of that behavior I think
is NATO or the way that NATO's been
behaving by putting military bases right
on the border of countries and then if
the countries get upset and invade
they're like you're the dude you you
can't put turrets in front of someone's
front door and expect that you're the
one that's under attack when they blow
up your turret like reasonable response
yeah they attacked your turret that was
attacking their space by encroaching on
it so like if you you can't that's just
this whole plane getting up in a cop's
face pushing or like you know getting
them to push you and then claiming
you're a victim you got up in the guy's
face if uh if any videos come out this
weekend I urge everyone to pay very
close attention to when that video
starts look for the editing that usually
comes to manipulate how uh how an
interaction started between law
enforcement that's uh always the first
thing you should pay attention to
because it speaks to their desire to uh
push you push you push you until you do
something back and then they have the
the weapon they need during Occupy Wall
Street there was a viral video that
showed several police officers striking
protesters and one cop was swinging his
baton like a baseball bat the occupiers
made a propaganda video where they
turned the Baton into a lightsaber to
make it funny and memeable and it was it
was clever and then someone later
released the full footage showing the
protesters attacking the police first
shaking a barricade trying to knock it
over and then one person hits the head
of the cop knocking his head off and
then the cop pulls the Baton sideways
starts pushing him back they start
hitting the cop back and then he starts
swinging the Baton they cut that out to
make it look like it's just the cops
swinging at these people and the funny
thing about all this is they started
saying because of my live streams you
can't edit this you can't fake it it's
raw it's live here's what they do they
would watch my live stream and then when
they did bad things they'd remain quiet
and then the moment the police attacked
they would take the link tweeted out
police attack innocent protesters
because anybody who tuned in at that
moment would only see the police
attacking protesters it's uh there's so
many ways to lie to people through all
like whether it's articles written like
Lie by structure where all the important
information comes in the last paragraph
of an article that's five paragraphs
long uh the in media whether it's audio
visual there's 10 000 more ways to lie
without actually lying have you seen
what Reuters reported about the shooting
former Christian School student shoots
up church and school oh yeah none of the
headlines none of the headlines had any
of the pertinent facts in any of the any
of the millions Lie by structure I would
like the way I'm shooting with this mass
murder by Audrey Hale like just to
remember just to leave the ideology out
of it if you can it's not about
transgenderism it's about a an adult
that's drugged up most likely drugged up
and like and just made to be crazy by
her parents or by her community or
whatever mental health issues and
perhaps exacerbated by our environment
or home runs or whatever we don't know
but we'd like to actually find out the
facts yes and don't blame transgender
people for this stupid woman's Behavior
like she's a psycho murderer that's a
person that's just a put that on Audrey
she did that nor should this be leading
to any legislation to take away gun
rights in my opinion because that's
going to be a trap people are going to
fall into because they're going to start
seeing this as a way to start taking
away gun rights and I don't think that's
the right thing to do I don't I mean was
she sorry I don't know how she got those
guns was she legally get those guns that
was the story there
yeah that a number of guns were like
purchased in addition to the um two
rifles there was one handgun that she
had present on her person at the time
when she engaged with the officers who
responded to the scene and there were
some reports that people are verifying
now as to whether or not there were
additional guns that were you know
procured but let me tell you something
like if you get a gun you get it legally
okay there are background checks there
is that the answer isn't to say oh we're
going to suspend you know rifles or guns
Etc it's like the people who pick them
up are the ones that are making these
choices that are doing this to engage in
that behavior how about actually caring
more about protecting soft targets and
children in schools because this keeps
happening because it is a vulnerable
asset for someone seeking to do harm and
take life they're not doing it other
places where they actually have armed
security and guards I mean look at every
single instance of this so when the
people say to me oh well you know this
is the problem because the person had
gone and they went in there and blah
blah blah blah and don't you love
children enough to actually stop and ban
these I love children enough to have
like retired military veterans Etc
retired law enforcement come in that
would like another job after they retire
go in there to protect children bring in
canine dogs Etc and Harden the target
then it makes it less desirable I know
this I was on the shooting team
officer-involved shooting team at any
time an officer had to discharge a
weapon and someone was killed at the
scene Etc to come and investigate and
clear the shooting so I've seen it I've
been there I've run all the courses
myself personally with weapons a
simulator for school shootings for
everything for preparedness for officers
to go in okay and that's what we also
need to do but unless we're willing to
make these tough decisions and actually
decide that children shouldn't be
collateral damage uh people who choose
to educate children should not be
allowed to be collateral damage then
you're going to see stuff like this
happen because evil like this is going
to follow the the path of least
resistance they will go into that school
they will try to take lives and there's
reports that this person went oh no but
about that there was somebody there with
security so then went back over you know
to this school like come on like figure
it out like look at the facts and stop
being like a hysterical you know uh
imbecile saying that the gun did it like
okay well how about people that get on a
train and they have knives or they have
whatever and they're causing harm and
stabbing people killing people like
that's what happens and I've seen it
over and over again for you know 20 plus
years of like investigating these cases
well you can try Banning knives like
they did in the UK but then people get
screwdrivers have you seen that great
picture of like the the UK cops you know
the American law enforcement they stand
in front of the thing of guns and drugs
and the UK cops are in front of a bunch
of like butter knives it's uh it's a
plastic scissors but here's the other
thing like right now they control the
narrative so well like if you go to
whether it's any celebrity that's
talking about this it immediately went
to gun control immediately like within
less than a half a day they were talking
about gun control and the The Narrative
has already shifted I remember somebody
did before like after Uvaldi talked
about uh what it would cost to get armed
security at every school in America and
it was like like five billion dollars or
something like that like right after we
spent 50 billion sent 50 billion to
Ukraine like it just proves to you like
who the hell they care about which is
not us so we got to secure you right is
that like one guard per building because
there's like nobody entrances in some of
these schools I think the the math that
they did it was like three well it was
like three yeah like that's not even an
average salary of like I think three is
better than zero and harming the
teachers is one way to go or we can give
it to salinsky that's that's fine we'll
just give it we're allowing teachers to
arm themselves well some some schools
have uh allowed that right
um I'm not so sure arming teachers is
the appropriate response I think
teachers should be allowed to be armed
but I think armed security makes the
most sense yeah but also there's plenty
of volunteers if you're just saying okay
this is going to cost as many billions
of dollars it's just a very reflexive uh
response that I think is just um you
know sophomore
um it's not actually Smart in terms of
actually analyzing what the you know
economic costs might be you know versus
actually you know the loss of life but
these are the same people that say you
know it's okay to abort your baby after
it's born if you get what I'm saying
I've sat in those courtrooms too with Dr
Phil Gosselin the maniac out of
Philadelphia that was literally drowning
uh children babies in the toilet after
they were born alive so you know these
are the same people like you know
championing those causes it's it's never
too much if it's Ukraine if it's uh to
promote you know the murder of uh
innocent children and babies and you
know what too much money if we have to
actually protect our children you know
in schools and by the way like I said
the Educators there's Educators there
there was ahead of the school whether
someone who's like the janitor the
teacher the maintenance guy like human
beings like um devoting themselves my
mother was a teacher I've worked as a
teacher I've worked in some really crazy
like schools in San Francisco that had a
lot of like you know people that had
problems with like juvenile crime and
whatnot but you know there's some
schools in certain areas they got metal
detectors but like don't be the person
that sits there with your Abacus and
you're deciding and playing with human
beings lives and children's lives to me
that is that's cowardice when we're
talking about gun control it's a little
bit of an abacus speaking of Abacus I
have one right here I know that's made
of Jade uh Tim you tweeted out yesterday
should we consider uh Banning people
that have hurting themselves I didn't
suggest anything I said should who have
a mental disorder with a higher
associated with a high rate of self-harm
be barred from owning guns I immediately
clicked no most people said yes
we're like yes it could be just an
emotional reaction to yesterday
is not what it is it's sort of an
emotional visceral reaction to what you
see and like getting tired emotionally
as a human being because you care of
seeing the same thing happen over and
over again and you want to come up with
a solution well so the the issue at hand
for a lot of people is that this
individual clearly was suffering from
some kind of mental distress what do you
think I I think the individual clearly
well it's a fact that the individual was
diagnosed and and I think that's what's
been reported with uh some with
depression anxiety uh gender dysphoria
things of that nature I don't know if I
care
um if someone has a mental illness I
don't I don't think second amendment
allows for you to borrow them from
wanting guns someone could be outright
schizophrenic
there would have to be a due process
adjudication and after due process your
rights can be curtailed right you can be
locked in a box if after due process you
can have your rights to a gun taken away
after due process so in that capacity
we have to recognize the challenge so a
lot of people said I don't think we
should ban guns in this way because they
will just pathologize conservative
thought and I'm like well yes they could
and then they will create a court system
with the judges they appoint to
adjudicate this and give you quote
unquote due process so it'll happen no
matter what with or without the Bill of
Rights
didn't they add masculinity to the DSM
recently So eventually was that really
yeah DSM-5 access to diagnosis like or
something like that they added toxic
masculinity I could be misremembering
that I thought somebody said that they
added masculinity to the to the DSM so
maybe at one point anyone who wants to
own a gun anyways would be seen as
somehow masculine or toxically masculine
crazy so the story was in 2019 they
called traditional masculine masculinity
harmful and face an upper armor I don't
know if it was added to the DSM-5 or
anything do they make the dsm-6 wouldn't
it yeah I don't um I'm concerned you
need the new version of the update by
the way that's the letters on the access
to diagnoses of the different you know
disorders that one can have you know
multiple
what was that the language that's the
language way that they get you to
remember it used to be toxic masculinity
now it's not that now it's just
traditional masculinity and eventually
it'll just be masculinity at all yeah at
all and then it'll just be men you can't
essentially a potential to harm yourself
is a reason to strip people's rights
because someone go online and be like
this world sucks man I hate myself and
then they'll be like oh go strip them of
his rights he's a David I disagree 5150.
yeah but you can go online and complain
about how horrible things are they're
not but a judge has to sign off on a
warrant if you express something uh if
you CR you've created this uh if you
present a clear and imminent threat to
yourself or others right 5150 taking
51.50 you then yeah right so if so just
because someone is diagnosed with
something doesn't mean they are a clear
and present danger to themselves or
anyone else so I do think for someone
like this or anyone the challenge here
is the red flag laws if if someone can
go and petition the government to file
some kind of claim against you take your
weapons here's the only thing I have
against it it's non-adversarial if
someone calls up a court and says I
believe Tim Poole is arrest for himself
for others they can serve me a notice
and then I'll have my lawyer answer it
and they can screw off because they need
probable cause proof and and due process
before they can deprive me of my rights
but what these red flag laws do is they
show up to your house and say don't
doesn't matter a judge said so no that
doesn't work that's that's not that's
not adversarial that the accused needs a
has a right has a right to defend
themselves in due process but that also
you're a thousand percent right and I
think it's it's very disconcerting
because we've seen this abuse of process
this lack of due process and what we
have seen recently just saying the
weaponization of not only the political
system but of the judicial system you
have activists judges on the bench I
don't care what side you're on the point
is it exists and you also have to be
careful who you get in front of Idaho is
a prosecutor every time we're like oh
geez you're going to get in front of you
know I knew if I was going to try a case
in like in Norwalk California they
called it no walk because the judges
there were like oh hell no they Dropped
a Bomb on you but then there was other
ones it was like guys nothing to see
here folks we can't even identify the
individual here has 17 aliases we don't
know who they are my cowboy fingerprint
them and run them through the system
next thing you know is our boom out the
door and they're out that's what's
happening in New York now so it all
depends and where you have these like
weaponized like District Attorney's
offices you know when I was at lad's
office and even San Francisco was more
liberal it wasn't like that but now we
have like yes you know this whole like
Soros like funding to all these
different guys that are very like
weaponized activists and you trace you
follow the money you see who's supported
who's made donations to them and then
you're the person that has an accusation
against you and you would appear in
front of that judge or you appear in
front of that D.A you know with the case
it's it's gotten very complicated put it
that way it will also price out people
who are poorer right because they can't
afford good legal counsel
the public defender's office but there's
some great public defenders out there
God bless you know tried a lot of cases
but that's uh that's roulette yeah
that's roulette you never know what
you're gonna get you think there's a way
to balance out the justice system like
judiciously with accorded judges I think
having having one judge with all that
power like you're explaining they can
they can fall and also lifetime
appointments is another situation with
some of them with the federal judges and
whatnot so it's it's pretty scary
because those people get entrenched in
there and they're you know they have
these different you know mission
objectives you know like before we so
say that you know court of appeals the
ninth Circuit Court of Appeal was like
where all like justice went to die
because they just had such an activist
agenda and then Trump started reporting
some other judges there to like balance
it out so people actually listen to the
cases versus just like rubber stamping
no by
I want to I want to jump to this next
story here from the post Malone we got a
lot of post-millennial stories today
FBI's former top profiler warns of
potential for contagious copycat crimes
in Nashville after school shooting
following such a shooting O'Toole said
that communities should remain on alert
for up to two weeks due to the potential
for copycats quote in 2000 when the FBI
released its first report on School
shooters we found that the copycat
influence was powerful and it influenced
the 18 cases that we studied this report
was compiled in the wake of the
Columbine High School shooting which
claimed the lives of 13 people O'Toole
said that she believed the shooter's
Manifesto should not be released in that
case over fears of the contagion effect
now there's there that's a fair point oh
I agree but I also want to know what's
in the manifesto because if but they're
censoring it now right people can't see
oh we're conducting our investigation
but no offense trust me part of that is
they don't want you to know so they'll
say that just like when all the pictures
emerged you know however they was like
oh take him down when they said oh
identifies his you know he him and they
started taking him down one after the
next people were screen shooting them to
preserve it so the public could actually
see before they could shape-shift The
Narrative well here's the debate
if this Manifesto comes out
and many of these far leftists agree
with it yeah it could be this Manifesto
could be a direct call to incitement it
probably is direct call to violence so
if it is and I assume it is
should it be released the alternative Is
We I think we need to know what
motivated this so we can stop it from
happening again you're a thousand
percent correct I was literally just
gonna say that how can you stop and
prevent something from happening in the
future if you don't understand it and
identify it and study it I mean it's
just you know that's like Blissful
ignorance gonna end in a fatal
conclusion my concern with the manifesto
being released is that it would be
doctored and then sent out with a
political agenda I mean it no one
there's no way to trust a document that
we see now like I can't I don't want it
I don't want it look at the video
footage if you want to see why what she
was doing uh and let's get her medical
history now she's no longer has her
rights she waived those rights to
Medical privacy after she killed all
those people I I I I I agree I think if
if they're not going to release the
manifesto and they're going to cite
copycat fears I'm fine with it I will
then choose to uh assume the motivation
as and I think it's fairly obvious so
unless they want to present any evidence
to the contrary this is clearly a far
leftist gender ideologue who killed
Christians because Christians are trying
to stop the mutilation of children hate
crime yeah well even then it won't
matter because it'll be called gender
affirming care and it won't matter
because people the average person who's
uninitiated to what's going on in the
world right now will see the Christians
as aggressors in a lot of these cases
because they're going to say you're
trying to prevent these kids like you
really do have to be steeped in not just
the ideology but the political
ramifications of all this together
otherwise it really does because of the
how intricately the media is able to
weave these stories together they will
come out looking like the bad guys and
if they can't the media will just stop
reporting on it like they always do if
you let yourself play identity here
it'll get used against you you need to
focus on the drug use of this kid this
this 28 year old woman right and how
long she's been on drugs has she been on
since she was 14. that's the that's the
focus Pharmaceuticals is that proven
here like I haven't seen a equip about
what chemicals she was using okay I mean
I like I'm has like without knowing that
like I would have to know that for sure
if that was actually part of it if she's
trans there's a chance that she's on
testosterone okay so that she was
actually doing the chemical process yeah
I mean where's the news where where I
want to know never going to come
sponsored by who who's sponsoring this
who sponsors the the networks that are
reporting on that's another thing about
like medical you know safety and getting
information out there because if there's
people right now being really severely
manipulated okay and to being like Oh
who am I am I binary am I this am I he
she my pronouns all this stuff it's like
mind-blowing to me how quickly this has
happened and you see a story like this
yeah no offense you're thinking twice
about all of this I've got to become
this person that person you hear all the
horror stories of people like regretting
that they're pushed into this whether
it's by abusive parents like the book
that you mentioned Tim
um genderqueer going through that
growing up in an abusive you know
environment and just questioning you
know your idea Identity or it's bad to
be a woman or it's bad to be a man toxic
masculinity then no one wants to be a
man now I want to be a woman oh it's
terrible to be a woman now I want to be
a man I mean it's insane the back and
forth and back and forth if you see a
situation like this hopefully people are
going to say wait I want to read about
this I want to understand and maybe it
gives you some reflection personal
reflection in your life about the
choices that you're making and how
you're being duped and totally
brainwashed by this you know by the
media and by these groups that actually
are trying to literally identify what
you might be despite what you're born
you know at Birth and teaching people in
hospitals to identify well this person
may be binary this baby that's like
three minutes old or it may be a a man
instead or a boy instead of a girl like
how is this even happening this is what
they're educating people about yeah I
want to give you a little Life Society
is going to tell you what they think you
are you get to tell Society what you are
real quick the the hill in the New York
Times and many others are reporting the
shooter was under doctor's care for an
emotional disorder but they did not
disclose the specific treatment okay so
I don't know what's the legal what's the
like the legality of if a murderer waves
do they waive their rights even a dead
murder do they have rights yeah I mean
like yeah what is their uh right to
privacy now that they've committed a
heinous horrific crime by the way not
open to speculation caught on video not
like this isn't a whodunit we know who
did it the person died at the scene
officers responded now we're getting
this information the public has a right
to know there should be transparency
here for the purpose of public education
to know what transpired here because
otherwise it will continue to lie and
tell us it's this this this this this
and try to you know modify shapeshift
the whole narrative so that it's
something that suits their ultimal
ideological you know pathway and end
game and that's why I have a problem
with it I want to know the facts I want
to know the facts I want to know the
facts I want to know what's actually in
the manifesto I understand I guess I
have a great concern about you know
Public Safety or copycats and
encouraging this and you know a lot of
colleagues you know at Fox that say and
one of my great colleagues a great
friend of mine Greg Gutfeld says if you
continue to report and do this it makes
highlights for copycats and it
encourages people to go out there and
repeat these crimes if we're giving it
energy if we're giving it life and
breathing into it all the time but there
has to be a balance between responsible
reporting to not encourage it and create
copycats and also allowing the public to
have a right to know the facts Etc
because rightfully so we have been come
distrustful of the corporate media and
the narrative that they push on us every
single day which by the way they have
proved to not be trustworthy when we
find out time and time again that what
they told us was bold-faced lives and
that's what I want to stop in this
country because this is America we
should be able to know it's not North
Korea or China or Russia is there a
precedent for a murder a dead murderer
like their their privacy being like okay
now that this person has committed the
crime they're dead we're going to
autopsy that we're going to find out all
their medical records is there is there
yeah well put it this way say for
example this was a case of where the
perpetrator was not you know DOA Dental
arrival killed on scene you know officer
interaction blah blah blah then you
would say this is an ongoing
investigation and because of that we
cannot release this information because
it would jeopardize the
um you know the the nature of our
investigation uh the legitimacy of it
and our ability to be able to catch the
ultimate perpetrator and bring them to
justice you don't have that here
and to your point that's what you're
saying you have someone who we actually
know who committed it and now we
actually need to know why how how this
transpired who else knew there was an
issue what kind of you know culpable
responsibility there is in order to
actually make sure this doesn't happen
again otherwise you're going to see the
same thing it's going to be you know
Parkland it's going to be Uvalde it's
going to be well it's going to be all
these things over and over again without
having an understanding that leads
towards prevention and protection of
Public Safety who would we petition to
get these medical records
found the case I love it uh well you
know I'll tell you what how about the
power of subpoena that Congress has
you've seen this right now you see it
with uh Jim Jordan and the rest of them
in Congress that are calling for
transparency they have the power of
subpoena to be able to bring people
forward whether it's the D.A Alvin Bragg
to understand what he's doing with the
weaponization politicization of the
office or whether it's the Twitter files
and all the different investigations
they have going on they're saying we
actually want the information we want
the information they could call for that
here as well and say we want to make
sure we're going to subpoena we want to
know exactly what the hell happened here
and we want to know what's in the
manifesto we want to know what you guys
are hiding from us and we the people and
who we represent have a right to know
with the power of subpoena you will be
forced to comply with it no one is above
the law whether you're a D.A you're a
judge you're the lead officer
investigating this Etc you subpoena the
doctor that was on that she was on the
try why not and let's see absolutely
protections but you should and you
should say uh what's going on here now
of course the doctor's going to be
afraid about personal liability Etc did
they know something was a crime
confessed to them or
um the intention to commit a crime the
intention to commit you know homicide
and Jewish school shooting or do a mass
shooting like this and we do know that
one friend was dm'd about this and there
was a suggestion that
um she wanted to commit suicide life was
not worth living that she was going to
do something really bad Etc then
everyone says okay well is that person
should they be liable for failing to
report and there's all kinds of
protections that go involved with that
whether it's turning collaboration
whether it's doctor patient privilege
but when the person who perpetuated the
crime and perpetrated it
commits it is killed then how is it that
we have a responsibility to someone who
is it's not like an open question of
what they're guilty or innocent yeah he
did it I would be okay with offering
immunity to the doctor and even
anonymity I'm not interested in hurting
that person even if they said to the
person do it even if they were inciting
it I don't care at this point I want to
know the chemicals yeah and what what
created what was sort of the the
cocktail behind this about history of
you know mental illness a history of
what self-mediation
um you know a history of like gender
dysphoria
um you know you know narcotics like who
knows but we do we do deserve to know we
should know otherwise what are you going
to do operate in a vacuum going forward
I don't know I think it's very dangerous
I'm getting fed up with the life I think
it's irresponsible yeah these shootings
are getting out of control I mean
obviously they're they're not a
controlled situation when they happen
but it before 1999 I didn't know about
school they didn't exist in my mind they
weren't part of the natural discourse
right to see more than one a year that's
just too much for me if you don't find
out the information then they look for
scapegoats well let's uh let's talk
about those scapegoats we have the story
from the New York Post NBC freelance
reporter ripped for linking Nashville
shooting to Ben Shapiro and the daily
wire he deleted it but Benjamin Ryan
tweeted NBC is ID the Nashville shooter
as Audrey Hale 28 who identifies
transgender and had no previous criminal
record Nashville is home to the Daily
wire a hub of anti-trans activity by
Matt Walsh blog Ben Shapiro and Michael
J Knowles
journalists that's what they call
themselves
they are they look I just don't see
I think I think a lot of conservatives
think this country is still unified and
they're shocked that journalists would
do these things there was just uh there
was just a thing in the New York Post
about how that patriotism in this
country is the lowest it's been in in
him and his like in the entire history
of this country patriotism and love
country have never been lower but what
I'm saying is I think conservatives
still believe there are rules
they they they think there are rules and
they demand you play by them and these
people are going okay I'll take the
Tweet down I'll just not get caught next
time
so while we keep trying to play this
game of can you believe these
institutions would say to the thing I
demand a retraction they're sitting in
their room laughing being like these
morons are still playing by the rules
while no one else is
also nobody sees the retraction anyways
and and nobody ever a little bit they
make money off it yeah but but in
general you post you post the article
first you get the rage out of it you
retract it later when all of that's
passed through and no you know maybe a
quarter of the people that saw the
initial one see the CVS it's good for
them
it's all about that but look they put
all kinds of false narratives in even if
they clear it up in the last final fifth
paragraph of it it's so disgusting and
dishonest it's reprehensible to me a
fake article journalist they're
propagandist a fake article will get one
million views and then a week later the
retraction will get another fifty
thousand that's one million 50 000 views
for their bottom line it's all at
Revenue did you say this article got
taken down no no his tweet he deleted it
and they make those and they post those
articles knowing they will likely have
to post a retraction later knowing that
if you're a propagandist you got your
word out there initially sure you have
to retract it later sure maybe a quarter
of the people see that but that's
another you know that's the rest that
did who gets the win exactly
think about what this tweet really means
though of course this reporter is trying
to frame it in a certain way and and
Link them but I'll put it this way if
Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh Michael Knowles
the daily wire are saying this is bad
this is dangerous and we need to do
something about it
and then
a trans person goes and shoots up a
church and school doesn't that prove the
daily wire correct that we need to pay
attention what's going on we need to
help these people and prevent these
tragedies from happening no you shift
The Narrative and make it about gun
control and say that people shouldn't
own guns and then immediately people
forget
but I think the uh the real answer is
yes yes we should it does prove that
there's a big problem right now with
drugging up people I think the gun
control narrative is a useful tool for
Democrats because absolutely it gives
you a never-ending problem something
that can never be solved 3D printed guns
exist and it what ends up happening is
the Democrats come out and they say
we're gonna we're gonna solve this
problem and then they ban some weird
random thing completely unrelated to
anything
then they say we did it did anyone I I
saw someone talking about how there
recently was gun control legislation
just signed by Joe Biden plus we had the
ATF rule did these things matter at all
they're talking about how one of the
weapons the two it was two AR-15s and a
handgun right but I'm pretty sure I
could be wrong you guys in the chat
correct me pretty sure one of the
weapons used by the shooter was an AR
style nine millimeter rifle so is that
it's like a five five six or anything
like that yeah so this salt style rifle
assault style which means nothing right
right and I I it is it is really
annoying how everyone the
post-millennial and the New York Post
are calling them assault rifles when
they're not AR Styles trigger semantics
every single day that's what they do
they use these Buzz words they're like
okay we're gonna trigger everybody with
this we're gonna say it and they know it
um you know words matter and they use
these words to alarm and to stigma you
know stigmatize people and create a
whole panic situation and like 99 of the
people out there that are doing this
whole total hysteria even Nancy Pelosi
came back from the dead to make a
comment about this I think freak Show
tales of the crypt and yeah hey I don't
know I was released there you go my aunt
talk about that
Thanksgiving nice wow you know but you
know but but I I call out the nonsense
you know I don't like people who are
dishonest they don't tell the truth
they're saying something to achieve
their ideological agenda their objective
and they will do it at any cost they
don't care if they're sitting there you
know telling a lie to the public
everything is a disinformation you know
campaign it's massive propaganda and by
the time we figure everything out you're
literally whatever or there's a
retraction or we actually find out like
Twitter files or whatever the damage is
done nothing to see here folks and
nobody see like that's nobody sees it
like I had to tell my dad about the
Twitter files and explain to him like
just how big TV and this happened yeah
like you have to explain to them how big
of a deal something like this is because
and no one rated him in most of the
culture whether you know not just
Boomers but a lot of people still they
put that faith in Legacy Media and the
in what they believe to be pure truth or
why would they lie right uh not
understanding that for-profit media like
that has it's baked into the business
model to lie it's a thousand percent but
it's also incentivized because it works
it actually creates profit because they
get people click bait to click on it and
that's it they don't care if they have
to retract it later was it like that no
consequence in the early days way way
worse now when did it shift you know I
like we had kind of mentioned before but
like when you went through I think 2016
election because of the whole Trump
derangement syndrome and all the
insanity that people like flipped out
about that
um then we went into 2020 election Shin
everything that transpired there then it
was the lockdowns you know with the
pandemic leading up to 2020 on people
all at home newsrooms change no one was
in the same room like we are right now
today going over stuff and then you had
a lot quite frankly of the young people
out there that were working in some of
these jobs Etc and like a very vocal
minority talking about how this made
them feel or that made them feel or you
know they were upset remember the Tom
Cotton stuff in the New York Times and
the editorial and then like everybody
was rioting at the New York Times saying
we were so disgusted to work for this
news organization how dare you you put
this you know opinion article up that he
had and it became that whole thing and
it really developed the perfect cocktail
the group think and that's what's sort
of taken over it's just like a complete
uh like sort of like a parasite takes
over right you have a host and you take
it over that's what's happened now in
terms of the thinking I just want to uh
a quick question while we're still in
the same segment people are mentioning
it the weapon used was a Kel-Tec Sub
2000 carbine nine millimeter variant so
important distinction so you're saying
that a lot of this disruption in media
and and I don't know your crackery or
whatever you want to call it this
breaking of the narrative is because the
newsrooms are diffused you're no longer
in person working together I think it's
one of the ingredients to the chaos
cocktail where it's like you have that
you had the pandemic people not together
you and and to be quite Frank like just
all the response like Donald Trump and
what he did and being an outsider and
someone coming in that wasn't part of
that political you know establishment
right but to be you saw the same thing
they didn't like it they stole from you
know Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders was
not partly established they wanted you
know Hillary Clinton uh you know anybody
you know but Trump someone that they
could establish so when you actually see
they're very similar the two sides they
mirror each other in the establishment
the way they want to control people in
the way you think and if you're are not
some of the Beats of that drummer plays
inside that system you're an agent of
chaos and they will do whatever it takes
to destroy you Bernie bent the knee and
shifted his policy positions I just
think there's no moral character there I
think there's no moral character there
he actually stood and believed in
something and then he showed himself to
be you know sort of a you know a false
prophet not someone who actually stood
for his principles and what he believed
in he also you know essentially let the
DNC and everyone take the you know the
nomination from him and gave it over to
Hillary Clinton not Joe Biden well they
had both they had all the moderates
right drop out at the same time and then
endorse Joe and then surprise it's
called collusion they get offered those
cushy jobs right you know you know what
I bet I bet they went to Buddha and said
look we'll make a transportation we'll
give you we'll give you some do nothing
job I don't know something like
Transportation sector 1000 and then he's
like all right works for me and then uh
oh now he's got to work that's why he's
nowhere to be seen that's why he's not
doing his job right that's why there's
all those train derailments right yeah
probably the deals were cut but that's
exactly how it works it's establishment
whether it's in left I know I know I
spent years being like a front row seat
to you know left this liberal Democrat
agenda even though I was a republican I
guess I was like a Sleeper Cell in there
and then I went on this side and I see
it so I see what the two extremes are
like and what they want to put together
and they're not that different in terms
of wanting to be able to control the
people within the party they're going to
play the party game and not Buck the
system or the establishment
I don't trust either side but that's
what I'm saying I don't trust Fox News
anymore than I trust CNN or MSNBC I'm
not telling you should it's pretty good
yeah sucker is pretty good everybody
else doctor and I love my team on the
five I know Greg is good yeah he's
fantastic they're very good the five is
very good except for the especially one
but the five is also in the weirdos in
the early days people could tell me I
was like Juan Williams no that's a
trigger word that's funny were you on
that show yeah
okay Juan Williams don't even get me
started I can't stand the guy but I
really do like that he's on the show
yeah well he they have put him on every
once in a while now he's sort of like
because you know whatever does the dude
even have Google is my question I don't
know but he doesn't really care because
I would say where are you getting that
what are you saying
um you know and he's like super angry
and just had all this Victory all about
stuff and I was like have you even met
this person do you know what you're
talking about and like look at me in the
eye when you're talking to me I liked
Bob Beckel Bob Beckel because he would
say and I go Bob what the hell I go
where are you getting that I go you just
made that up she goes yeah so
hey what do I care you know because he
like ran mondales like he got like once
he won one state he goes and I had to
pay for it wow let me ask you though so
you you've been working in politics and
media for for a long time and in the
past 10 years we've started to see this
this dramatic shift right you you worked
it's you worked at CNN right with
Anderson and now CNN they went
absolutely insane but they weren't like
that I'm telling you and people no I
know I look back and look at it Larry
King we covered all the legal cases and
political cases Anderson Cooper I've
always actually personally really liked
um we got along really well he recruited
me to come you know to CNN and they
weren't like that I worked with like
Wolf Blitzer and you know Lou Dobbs was
there at the time and it was like a
normal place it was actually kind of
cool you know to be there I used to
watch CNN I just have CNN on 24 7.
everyone did because it would give me
the breaking news and the breaking news
happened oh yeah but CNN Headline News
too but then one day I noticed all it
was was panels talking about Donald
Trump and I switched to Fox and it was
Iranian protests I switched to CNN Trump
switched to Fox terrible weather coming
your way storms and disaster Fox News
extreme weather center I I got to ask
you for a lot of people who have only
seen this from the outside I'm wondering
what was your experience inside watching
this weird polarization in the shift
happening not just in in news but in
politics especially considering your
work in San Francisco yeah you know it's
so interesting because I was first lady
of San Francisco right because that like
we're not going to try to hide this it's
like on the internet but I was married
to Avenues and was the governor but at
the time San Francisco wasn't even that
bad then before a DA's office was good
mayor's office was good San Francisco
was clean it wasn't like your right
privilege and you get like you know gold
medal to like defecate on the streets in
front of kids like it wasn't you were
you were married to the man clearly
there was something good and and that
you saw in all of that that's not there
anymore okay well yeah I saw somebody it
was very hard working and actually
really cared about people and really
embraced the idea of being a public
servant like I did working for the
District Attorney's office and trying to
do good and do something incredible for
the community and that all involved you
know actually you know Law and Order and
making sure there was not like chaos in
the streets if they were safe the
communities were safe the children could
walk to school that you know people
could you know raise their kids in
different communities you could invest
and buy something that added and in an
increased in value Right Live your
American Dream all the above San
Francisco absolutely beautiful place we
did care not cash Gavin Newsom did that
what was that well so care.cash was we
are not going to subsidize addiction and
poly substance abusers by sitting there
and giving them cash to just feed their
addiction and kill them to just
essentially be an accomplice to take a
life to actually try to battle back to
give people
um you know drug counseling treatment
get them clean help them with uh getting
a new job helping to reunite family
reunification uh whether you know if
they ended up in the court system
Etc we'd have drug court and help people
actually through the process and care
about them instead of just like throwing
a buck at it and saying your life isn't
really mattering to this community we're
just gonna put you to the side for a
second here et cetera et cetera so my
question is with all of those good
things you are seeing and doing did you
actually witness the brain slug enter
Gavin's ear and take over his mind and
turn him into whatever it is he is today
sad figuratively right but maybe
literally I don't know it couldn't have
gone through the jail through the gel
but how did how did he go from because
there was a whole movement that became
this super like liberal left like woke
agenda that is extremely persuasive and
aggressive and if you're not going to
stand on principle like they'll they'll
tsunami over you they will destroy you I
literally had people coming to my house
where he and I lived protesting lighting
sofas and on fire in front of our house
I would have to go out there with the
hose and I didn't care I was like you're
gonna come to my house like now you're
doing an aggressive act against me and
now it's you and I let's go so I'm like
like shooting the hoes at people they're
ringing my doorbell all hours of the
night they're like gavinism doesn't care
about anybody he's like attilodon you
have no idea the narrative was so
different he was the most conservative
person and moderate like responsible
about taxes and incredible programs for
small businesses all the above then we
saw people come in like the quote
Bicycle Coalition you cannot believe the
power of the very vocal minority that
comes in with their really weaponized
agenda and how they will spend their
entire lives to destroy you and try to
make a point across so that they become
the loudest noise that you cater to and
I've seen it happen over the years and
we've seen this with the woke media and
what's gone on and and you see it also
quite frankly with um you know the
mainstream like corporate weaponized
media now doing the exact same thing and
it's just happened you know one vicious
cycle after the next I will say probably
the ascendancy of Donald Trump help feed
this in that people became so upset so
deranged so obsessed like addicted to
Donald Trump and Trump's Arrangements
into I think it's a thousand percent
real we've seen it at all across all the
different election things campaigns
events all of the above that literally
they're like we have to move like in
unison against this one you know entity
dangerous like force and movement in the
country and so it was just a complete
slingshot of aggression back in the
other in the other way you know to try
to stop it California orders skilled
nursing facilities to accept coronavirus
patients from the LA Times April 1st
2020. I don't understand how when you
look at Newsome Cuomo I think wolf uh
who what what other was it uh Murphy was
that one of the governors
um Whitmore uh Whitmer Whitmore they
were putting coveted patients into
nursing homes and killing the elderly
and and Newsome is one of the governors
not a listen um it's it's very upsetting
to me you know he and I still have
actually a very good relationship I've
had to clear up a few things
um recently with him
um he enjoyed a very good relationship
with Donald Trump even went so far as to
say promises made you know Promises Kept
when uh djt went out there you know for
California for the fires we went out
with Jared Etc
um giving relief there happy you know
working cooperatively together but now
you find themselves on more kind of like
Polar Opposites there's a whole looping
election there's the chance if Biden
runs there's Kamala is Gavin Newsom
going to run so it becomes obviously you
know incredibly complex let's see if my
ex-husband runs against my future
father-in-law I don't want to just keep
popping on him though I'm curious about
you know what what was this cultural
shift in media and across the board that
I mean just to elaborate on the
experience for for for me when I started
working advice I wanted to be there
because they were edgy because they were
not establishment Shane Smith the CEO
had gone on Colbert and said look we're
not left not right we don't want to do
anything we just want to tell these
stories and then within a few years I
saw the transformation happening I'm
like I'm getting out of here and then I
went and worked for another company that
was new and then within eight months
boom they were getting woke of course
they went broke laid everybody off I'm
just I'm just curious your perspective
on how this how this happens to these
companies I mean I I think you know okay
I'll tell you this because I also had
worked at you know MSNBC but like
filling in doing analysis and you know
filling in like prime time and like for
Danny Abrams I was part of his show
everyone was trying to kind of do the
same thing right except Fox yeah was
definitely more conservative for sure
but they're not even that conservative
these days to begin with you know what I
mean Tucker's fantastic I think like the
five I mean whatever but um MSNBC made a
you know conscientious decision from a
management perspective to go ahead and
be the counter programming to Fox News
that's what happened first in terms of
the big you know cable news networks
then seeing the success that MSNBC was
having in the counter programming like
you have to remember back there were
nights like Rachel Maddow you know Urban
everybody doing incredibly well on the
ratings like giving Fox a run for their
money okay and we were like you know the
the you know engine that couldn't fail
were like propelling for with like
smashing ratings then CNN saw what was
happening with MSNBC and decided they
would follow suit so then you had
someone like Jeff Zucker who was super
Trump The Apprentice everything you know
besties at weddings together you know
all the above come in and try to push
CNN to that extreme when you know Don
Lemon then Don Lemon uh you know Cuomo
who by the way I worked with at ABC News
and Good Morning America
was not this person that was like a
super leftist or anything like that but
it becomes that reward you know what I
mean it's like classical Condition it's
like okay I'm gonna do this oh it
actually worked out well I'm going to
continue to do that so you saw CNN do it
but they relate to the game that failed
for them as an economic model okay and
it didn't work it didn't ring true they
weren't able to capitalize on it and you
saw their like online thing the CNN
digital total collapse no infrastructure
no authenticity and then layoffs Zucker
all of the above so CNN's in a free fall
with like horrific ratings right now
right it began to like drop down with
MSNBC you had the pandemic you had Trump
you had all these movements and you had
the mainstream media the print
journalism also being very aggressive
um trying you know following through
with that to say like this is not what
we want and making all these constant
attacks and attacks then you also saw
the political process weaponized against
conservatives against Trump with all
these different investigations that
later out turned out to not bear any
fruit right but it's actually what paid
for them to continue editorially to go
after him and demonize it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy they're making
it happen right the only reason anyone
was interested in pursuing it was
because they were getting pressure
because the media was it was a swirling
toilet it was a flush sending us down
into a into the sewers of you know
politics you advise your advisor to
Donald J Trump yes senior advisor what I
got from looking at it now looking back
is that he came in and without even
realizing it posed a threat to this
change of guard from the liberal
economic order to the new world order
that they're trying to create where
they're they don't want American
military bases they want to create some
Global technocracy and he wasn't part of
the establishment it seemed like he
didn't know that he was in the way like
he ended the trans-pacific partnership
which I thought was a brilliant move for
American sovereignty so now these
Malaysian oil companies can't sue us as
Citizens it's held NATO accountable but
that pissed off this this oligarchy that
wants to transition did he know that he
was doing that or was he just doing what
he thought was the best for the country
I'll tell you something he actually he
does what he thinks is best he'll listen
to your opinion your Viewpoint he'll
make a decision but um he actually will
analyze it and decide but he operates
from a businessman's prism and
perspective so you know and we haven't
really had like real businessmen you
know occupy we certainly don't have one
right now he doesn't have any business
experience Joe Biden right we see what's
happened with the economy and whatnot
but Donald Trump approached it like that
he's like well why are we giving all
this money to these people they're not
painting why are we giving all this
money to Nato they're not contributing
anything why are we giving this money to
China why are we doing this and this and
this and he actually asked the questions
like why are we doing this and then he
would get the answers and then you know
decide what needed to happen in order to
represent America's interest he doesn't
apologize for being someone that
represents the United States and what
our best interest is for the American
economy for manufacturing for
infrastructure you know creating jobs
and Economic Opportunity across the
board taxes Etc and you know but he he
operates from a different perspective he
looks at it like what makes sense to me
and I'm not just going to do it this way
because the establishment left or right
has been doing it this way forever it
seems like he posed a threat to this
transition of order and so they were
like crap we can't tell people that he's
a threat because they don't know that
we're doing this we're doing it kind of
undercover they don't know we're
transitioning from the liberal economic
that we're selling out the American
power structure to create a global power
structure right just like the Paris
climate change Accord all the above that
was like Hey all the good old boys let's
all play ball bro let's we're all for
the environment blah he's like what the
hell why are we paying into this you
know what are we doing for that about
Jesus he's like China's the biggest
polluter and they're not paying the dime
why are we paying all this money and
kissing everybody's ass he goes if that
it looks like that's how he talks he's
like this is no way it looks like what
happened is they were like introduced
okay he's a problem we don't want to
tell people why introduce identity
politics and then he bit and he fell
into it and he started talking about
leftism and I'm like I disagree well
actually didn't he not start getting
traction during the campaign until he
started tweeting more uh more stuff like
that he started tweeting out leftism in
2017. okay it was that I think that what
happens is the culture wars started just
slightly before Occupy Wall Street
Occupy Wall Street absorbed a lot of
this stuff good point and then you got
gamergate in 2013 and so a lot of people
started experiencing this this cultural
phenomenon this shift I went to a trump
rally in I think it was in Wisconsin
somewhere and I asked some older folks
uh I don't mean old but you know 50 50s
and these guys were like look Trump's
talking about bringing jobs back he's
talking about helping the union guys
talking about helping the working guy
securing our borders I'm all for it and
then I talked to some 20 year olds and
they were like he's against political
correctness and I respect that he speaks
the way he wants to without fear of
censorship and we're really worried
about what's happening culturally
I think that greatly benefited Trump
both are true early on and so I don't
think it's that he decided hey I'll use
this I think he was the Avatar of the
Rage of the working class and those who
are sick of the hoity-toity political
right just left this culture forgotten
men and women that were left behind
which is true but they were left behind
by both parties and he makes that very
clear and I saw that when I went to
Florida a woman told me I asked her uh I
was at the it was a I was in Fort
Lauderdale I can't remember exactly
which rally it was
and I asked this woman I was like so are
you you're here to support Trump are you
a Republican Jose oh no I've never voted
right and I'm like this is the first
like yeah she's like I've never cared
for it but he's finally speaking up and
the reporting at the time in 2016 was
that areas of the country that
traditionally weren't really democrat or
republican were lighting up and turning
Republican because finally someone was
speaking to these people so here what I
think right now is to go on on what you
were saying Ian about that I'm relatable
absolutely and to to elaborate on what
you were saying about the threat to this
this order
I think you've got elements of the US
government that want the U.S to fail
Donald Trump gets elected and I think
you know his whole strategy is here's
how we're going to help America survive
and rebuild it and that's a problem for
those who have investments in foreign
countries I'll put it this way you got
these guys in government who have
effectively put put options on the US
economy yes and Donald Trump is now
jeopardizing their bet against America
by making it stronger and it's making
these people very poor they're very
angry about it I got the feeling that he
didn't realize that that he was doing it
that he was threatening some secret
transition I don't know if he knew I
don't think he knew I just it felt like
he was just doing what he thought was
the best for the country from the base I
think he knew that it was going to piss
all those people off because they
certainly called and complained a lot of
people you know he had people on both
sides and believe me they call and talk
to him and whatever but at the end of
the day like you're one thing you're not
gonna do you're not going to be able to
successfully like Bully Trump you're
just not he doesn't care he's going to
do what he but thanks he tells you
exactly what he thinks and he's gonna do
what he says that's how he is and
sometimes it may be frustrating like
whoa wait we got a win here like don't
say anything else about that you're
never going to win that conversation
with him because he's always going to
save it trust me but if you know he's
always going to react away you can use
that against him and get him to do what
you want I think he is unpredictable it
really is I agree I do agree with that
predictable one thing that was he'll
change his opinion believe me he could
be in here right now and you could say
something to him and he's like
and he said think about it then you
could come and say something to him and
he's going to think about that and then
you're going to see where he comes down
on it it's and you can't imagine like
whoa I didn't see that come why didn't
he go this way on that or blah blah blah
and he has the way he processes and he
thinks about things and he's a very
confident person meaning he knows what
he wants to do what he thinks and he's
going to do ultimately it doesn't matter
what he thinks is right in his mind
hello and thanks for letting us cycle
analyze you on TV is he going to win in
2024 I think so yeah I especially think
with everything that's like transpired
now what's going on with the
investigations with the District
Attorney's Office coming after him
whether it was you know Mar-A-Lago and
the insanity insanity and I remember
that night so well then coming in and
you know storming Mar-A-Lago like how
insane is that and you're going through
like melania's closet like what is wrong
with these people like seriously
seriously if they can do it to him guess
where they can come in
I love your side in the front no
trespassing yeah
you better have a warrant I was like I
like this I mean but it's true right I
mean this is America and that you have
to stand up for what you believe in and
if you think it's okay that they're
gonna do this it's time and time again
on President Trump and like where's the
evidence where's the evidence of any of
the wrong doing and then it's Joe Biden
is sitting there living his best
Corvette Summer with a you know box of
docs in the garage with like crackhead
Hunter and like China like four you
couldn't make this up people be like
whoa whoa they'll be like what
medication are you on that you wrote
this script because no one will believe
it no one believe it but it's actually
happening in this country I do worry
that enough people are even getting this
information the amount of people that
didn't hear about Hunter Biden just
because of the media's ability to
censorship to censor it or to prevent it
from coming out at a politically
expedient time uh I think the biggest
uphill battle isn't just
um they did that to affect the election
yes
the New York Post just tweets on Hunter
Biden and now how many years we're
finding out it was actually true there
was like veracity and you know truth to
it there was evidence to back it up
there's evidence of foreign dear links
there's evidence of you know uh being in
bed with China and you know a million
dollars here there whatever I'm like
come on I mean come on and why is that
guy still running around I gotta ask
about Ron DeSantis is it do who oh he's
just he's this guy I don't know if you
heard of Honey D he's over in Florida uh
he hasn't announced but obviously
everyone thinks he's gonna run what do
you think do you think obviously you
don't think he's going to win because
Trump's going to win well listen um
you're asking my honest opinion and I
would tell you and right now you know in
this moment of time I think thousand
percent Trump is going to you know win
the primary he will be the nominee and I
don't see anybody I mean do you I mean
let me know no I completely agree let me
know if you you know anybody or think
that there's anybody on the left that
can beat Trump in the general election
if you have a legitimate election where
votes are cast and one vote one whatever
just saying right how the whole system
works and I go and put my vote down
there you go ma'am thank you so much
boom boom boom boom boom who who now
that you have buying an office and you
have that juxtaposition and you see what
he has done have been a total abysmal
failure nor did I expect anything else
because he doesn't have the business
Acumen or the experience he's not a CEO
he's not a businessman he is a failed
career politician of 50 years sponging
off the backs of the taxpayers that guy
that dog don't hunt okay there we go
Daddy you got Kamala Harris who I worked
with in the DA's office all right now
the whole world knows what I already
knew okay that she is completely
incapable incompetent and actually
caught a Fright Night terrifying attack
like it's not good the cackling laugh
and whatever Halloween should just come
one time a year didn't you not even and
then Gavin who wants any of this I think
you want California Kamala didn't even
get one delegate right Chelsea gabber
got one pretty sure I like her the only
person that could beat Trump is Michelle
Obama
I don't know if she has any aspiration
to even do it but she's just famous and
has that name right there was people
like Michelle Obama or I don't even know
if I buy that anymore because we're in
such a highly politicized time the
Obamas succeeded like vastly on the idea
that we just didn't talk about how bad
things were at the time and if you're
not politically aware and you're not
paying attention to what's going on you
just assume that everything is going
good and I think that is partially to do
with the fact that the media pushed what
we would call now globalism but was a
neoliberal policies in the world so you
just assumed if you weren't paying
attention to politics that everything
was going good The World Isn't like that
anymore we're highly we're highly highly
divided right now I think if the
election were held right now Donald
Trump would win
based on the economy uh and that's the
the biggest Factor based on what's going
on with Ukraine the wars we're at a
point what happened in Afghanistan
absolutely
and and Trump said all of this was going
to happen when he was campaigning and
and here we are now I think it's you you
can get a Joe Biden in when no one knows
what to expect but now we know exactly
what to expect and it's apocalyptic
Trump's going to walk into back remember
2019 member of the economy remember how
much money you made I'm gonna bring it
back and they're going to be like yes
please remember graphene to that point
this is it with all the dustrials with
all the talk about Ron DeSantis I don't
see him being able to get anywhere near
close here's the deal Rhonda Santos uh
you know if I got you know and his wife
good job I know yeah I know them very
well Don Jr and I in the president
campaigned uh you know vigorously for
them raising money all the above when he
was very down at the poll so Trump's
just like bro like I helped you out you
know I did a great job for you you we're
gonna lose to this freak Show guy down
there and I helped you and you know God
bless how about this
be smart be a strategist you're doing a
good job in Florida why don't you
continue to actually do your job in
Florida
Trump is going to run he smashed 16
insanely qualified candidates in 2016. I
mean smashed them to living hell okay
hilariously hilariously I mean it's like
oh that one low energy jab he just fell
off the stage like whatever and then now
you're gonna think you're gonna go in
you're not like I'm telling you this guy
and I was the first one to support him
at Fox because I knew the man like I
said you know he's my friend for 18
years I know the measure of the guy I
know what he's capable of I know that he
is somebody that you're not going to be
able to like defeat you can't break this
guy you cannot no matter what happens I
think he's made from a different whole
kind of like DNA why don't you just run
like do your office and then run be the
appointed one of the you know Maga
movement etc etc the populist movement
the America first movement instead of
now you're putting yourself up in front
of a firing squad of people who are
literally so pro-trump because Trump
actually did a good job we don't wonder
about the job that he did he did a great
job do you want someone going in there
with like you know like training wheels
on to try to fix this mess that they
made or do you want a guy that you know
that can actually do the job and kick
ass or someone who's respected what
about from National Security perspective
okay because the rest of her making a
joke out of us look at North Korea look
at crazy go get a little rocket man he's
going nuts uh you know Vlad a lot of
cats going nuts no one cared they're
like laughing at the United States the
NATO's like no one cares because there's
nobody of any substance whatsoever this
guy was sitting there talking about chop
chocolate chip ice cream when children
were murdered is that the leader you
want in the white house that's what I'm
saying so that's what I'm telling you
vice president's gonna win I think
Trump's going to win too all right vice
president I I so I don't know that I
would there was a period where I said
Rhonda said this maybe now I'm thinking
I said carry a lake maybe but I'm seeing
a lot of people be like no she's too
like Trump and you need kind of that
contrast I don't know she's a female I
think Minnie she's not that like him
this is this is what I was saying about
um the extradition threat me indictment
against Donald Trump Ron DeSantis
statement was very disappointing to me I
think he's done a great job in Florida I
think he's done a lot of really
tremendous things that's why so many
people moved there so many people voted
for him but he said look I'm not going
to get involved in this and my response
was the governor should have said mark
my words you will not lay a hand on
Donald Trump in my state and Carrie Lake
would have said that you tweeted uh
Trump 2024. oh yeah absolutely I saw it
I retweeted it I retweeted I checked my
feet I was I was a year ago I was like I
think DeSantis but things change and
what the problem I had was all I saw
from Trump was 2020 2020 just kept
talking about it and so I was just like
I don't see anything here I know that
annoyed people but now you'd be pissed
if you thought that you know something
was taken from you and that you thought
both were counted that sure you know
weren't real or actual or you know
saying that's a whole other thing if
that's what he thinks I understand his
feelings but all that mattered to me now
is especially seeing East Palestine
going down down there buying McDonald's
for people was a grand slam absolutely
seeing him put out these videos where he
talks about policy policies that I
actually care about you like those
policy videos I think they're very good
absolutely he has specifics it's not
just uh you know flowy rhetoric in 2020
around August I said okay I'm gonna vote
for this guy I didn't vote for him the
first time I said earlier I probably
wouldn't vote for him but when he
released his second term agenda I was
like okay this is pretty good the school
choice was huge getting rid of the
critical race Theory and government
contracts all of that stuff and so now
him putting out these policy videos I'm
like
You Know Carl Benjamin of the Lotus
Eaters podcast hit me up and he says Tim
you're wrong about DeSantis Trump has to
finish his narrative Arc let me explain
and he's got this video where he breaks
down Trump's story is not over he has a
mission to accomplish and that did mean
something to me and then when I saw
everything you know the campaigning he's
begun doing I thought his announcement
speech was actually good A lot of people
were like I didn't like it I thought it
was good I thought the videos you put
out were great and then what really put
me over the 50 Mark was when he bought
McDonald's for people and he said I know
about the menu better than you do and
then everyone's laughing and I'm like
that that is a total fact by the way a
lot of times I've had McDonald's with
him and I have McDonald's today and were
we not laughing about it and talking
about okay what is djt like I'm like
okay well he likes to get the chicken
nuggets like it's a fish sandwich like I
said the quarter pounder with the cheese
this is what we eat it's good huh oh I
fueled myself up with it today but I
just think I don't touch that you know
when when when he is not all of it but I
don't like the bread yeah I'm not gonna
eat McDonald's but when he bought all
the McDonald's for everybody at the
White House for that sporting thing you
know that's that that is personable it's
relatable when he went to East Palestine
I thought to myself uh we had Benny
Johnson on Benny said Joe Biden
literally went to the furthest part of
the globe he went
on the other side of the planet from
Ohio right and then my response was hey
look and on President's Day Marion
Williamson announces she's running I
think she's a very nice lady she did not
go there the vague ramaswami I think
he's brilliant he's a man he's amazing
he didn't go there either is that who
you want yeah
and so I'm thinking even take it back to
the nest these these other people who
are running for president didn't bother
to go to East palestinos it's big in the
news these people's lives are destroyed
and Trump's like I'm going down there
even if you thought it's a PR stunt and
that's what some people in the corporate
left press were saying they were like
Trump's playing politics it's a stunt
and I'm like oh so if I vote for a guy
my worst case scenario is in an attempt
to to uh earn favor with the public
he'll do good things to him he'll do the
right thing and I can tell you it wasn't
I'll take it because he's not a stunt
kind of guy he actually was like this is
outrageous this guy's not going at
what's wrong with this guy that's how he
talks and then he's like I'm gonna go
there then he's gonna buy people
McDonald's loves McDonald's he loves
Pizza Hut and I'll try to like throw
like props up but I'm just telling you
what he eats he likes that a lot and we
went to the Kentucky huh no Papa John's
well your new pizza thing yeah oh yeah
me and Jack was over but we're gonna
open a pizza restaurant yeah stay tuned
I'll build a recipe
it sounds just pepperoni pizza in the
American Girl dolls they released like a
90s Classics Edition it's got the Pizza
Hut cups that you always talk about the
the 90s cups the Red Cups I thought um
he likes that in Kentucky Fried Chicken
just say when the Kentucky uh Derby and
I said it's very good we're gonna go
back we're gonna get the Kentucky Fried
Chicken so we had a total Feast of that
we have to be careful I want your
service is gonna have to jump in front
of his diet
they're running the Kentucky Fried
Chicken you know people find it
relatable all the billionaire but he
wants to eat but he wants to eat that's
what all things aside that's in shape
all things aside I want to see Trump's
Revenge I want to see him debate like a
real debate where they don't hate each
other they just are straightforward like
him and it is the sanus whatever vivex
great because he's smart he can talk
about economics because he needs I think
Trump he doesn't need it but humility if
you show him like weak for a moment and
then he's able to still find the right
way through the weekend he's gonna do it
I want a little debates with like
Hillary Clinton when she tried to hit
him with the tax credits you had a
chance to get rid of him and you and all
your donors are benefiting from it so
yeah some of them are pretty bad like
but you should have done something about
it to change it so they're on the books
I took advantage of it next question I
want to see in 2024 Trump get revenge I
want him on who give me the list of
Vengeance man I don't like it no no no
no no Donald Trump wins and they
immediately start accusing him of being
a Russian they run this massive
ridiculous nonsense investigation which
was just Bonkers they accuse him of
doing what Joe Biden did with the quid
pro quo in Ukraine they they put they
strapped weights to his ankles and we
still had what Jim Cramer called the
best numbers of Our Lives despite that
guy's got no credibility but it was so
good even he couldn't have been wrong
which is kind of funny so 2019 we saw
this really great economy despite all
the things they were doing to weigh him
down I want to see Donald Trump get in
and actually care at his agenda
untethered and then fire all of these
people right and get the job done that
he was supposed to get done a lot of
people said he didn't drain the swamp a
lot of people said he did and all it did
was expose the swap monsters standing in
the field the next thing thing he needs
to do is fire them all I I don't
disagree but just so you understand this
man works like
um I don't know 18 out of 24. I know
he's up super late he's you know awake
very early he is constantly working
constantly writing this stuff down and
he is literally just waiting for that
day of reckoning you just wait and say
wait and say it seems like the tethers
like you were saying cover yourself in
plastic because this is gonna be next I
don't know how to how to move through
the tethers it feels like the system is
organized so that it's impossible to
defeat it but I mean not impossible
obviously but well look and I don't want
to hurt people say stuff like you know
like you mentioned oh the swamp has
teeth it actually does because there are
career politicians there's people in
positions
um that they're actually very difficult
to remove but this is why also I say
it's such a great Opera opportunity to
have someone that already went in did a
phenomenal job if you look at all the
metrics you know across the board
whether it's National Security and
foreign policy or you know manufacturing
infrastructure you know record low
unemployment you know record high
numbers of you know latino female
entrepreneurs and businesses you know
open it was 1800 a day at one point a
female do we have to worry do we have to
worry about him winning back
Independence because I think that a lot
of Independents right now don't want to
touch him why why do you say that I find
that I find that an interesting
statement because I think Independents
and Libertarians and people like that
are like you know what I don't like what
the government's been doing maybe now I
think like maybe now in like I think
it's better now with like that
opportunity might be better now given
like what we're experiencing
economically and all that stuff but I
just worry that for a lot of it like
look a lot of people like when I was
trying to explain to people why I voted
the way I did because that happened like
people like why would you vote that way
and I had to give them a list of the
things that uh that I approved of
whether it was the Abraham Accords
whether it's uh NATO all these things
you explained it to them most of them
first of all if they're even if they're
either low info voters or if they're
politically left they're not going to
care because they either don't know
what's going on the because the CNN none
of these companies have you know none of
these media Outlets have reported on it
anyways so they're at a disadvantaged
media wise but for The Independents I
just I don't know where they go I think
The Independents are going to have a
hard time who are they going to go
They're not going to go to Biden the
well I'm saying but if he's gonna have
to he's going to have to be DeSantis
here and that was in that respect I
think a lot of people see him as a as a
different option well also just like
real quickly DeSantis
um is actually hurting himself right now
and it's not smart and I don't like it
because he's my daughter I want him to
do well uh you know not standing for
Trump not like saying you know Trump is
a Floridian like that's one of his that
part he represents Donald Trump you know
as somebody who is a taxpayer in Florida
and is a resident so it should be like
no no no way hands on this guy you know
this is outrageous you could add like
Dragon man Etc are for you know a
made-up crime whatnot he could have
showed courage and Leadership and that
was a really rare opportunity it was a
strategic misstep and he's also going to
be very severely injured by Trump going
up against him in any primary I think
it's me very difficulties
one of the things I think that the
reasons The Independents are having
concerns with Trump right now is because
of the way he handled covid and giving
fauci all that power and just letting
him let go he didn't like fauci one bit
he said no he hated him nobody really
seen him no one no one that I know
really liked him if you look back at
some of those press conferences like
Trump was trying to not not let him talk
and whatever he like him at all I think
that if he acknowledges that he made a
mistake which as somewhat in the past
seems out of character for the guy but
it's like putting fauci in power and
letting him run with it after she was
already yeah on the podium and standing
behind him like that's a big a big thing
well he was super annoying
if you can acknowledge that that was an
issue I think I mean he hit him actually
pretty hard if you look at some of the
Reddit I get what you're saying I am no
fouchy fan but you know Trump's not like
not a fouchy fan now he was never a
fouchy fan a period full stop not one
day of his life I am promising you this
what he wanted to do was save lives and
try to protect people while not shutting
down the American economy and hurting
children and schools okay so yes he
tried to get you know the vaccination
and stuff and like find like remedies
and things like that
um so that people could actually get
some medicine so that you could you know
curtail the loss of life okay but he
wasn't the guy putting you know people
locking down you know on elderly
establishments and rest homes and
putting people in there and letting them
die of covid
we're gonna go to super chats and we'll
carry on with that conversation for the
members only section because there's a
lot to talk about but uh for now I want
to make sure we can get in your
questions while we're here so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends and
head over to timcast.com click join us
in the menu bar become a member and then
sign up for our Discord server and then
you can watch our members only
uncensored show it's up on the front
page of timcast.com at about 10 10 p.m
and if you're in the Discord your chat
will be live on the show and you can
even submit questions to call into the
show and talk to us yourself for the
time being we will read your super chats
Jordan Henry says Tim your deleted tweet
about the shooter's different shoes is
worth looking into those are clearly not
the same shoes WTF yes I tweeted about
this earlier because when we were
looking at I should say what I was
looking at the surveillance footage
released to the shooter as well as the
body camera footage I noticed the shoes
are different yeah I don't know what
that means or if it means anything uh
the reason I deleted the Tweet right
after I posted it was because we're
getting ready for the show and I didn't
have time to actually pull the videos
and then actually make something to be
like hey this is what I'm talking about
so it looks like it could be artifacting
from granny video but the surveillance
footage actually seems to be high
resolution if you watch the surveillance
footage yourself it does appear that the
perpetrator is wearing black shoes with
a white streak but then later in the
police body camera footage the shooter
is wearing Vans with a flame on the side
of them
all that means potentially if it's true
because maybe it's just a a camera trick
that erases the light like erases the
color because of the light it means they
change their shoes that that's not
surprising to me in the least bit
doesn't mean anything I don't even know
what it would mean if it did mean
anything at all so they changed their
shoes okay A lot of people are claiming
conspiracy theories and I'm like all I
said was it looks like the shoes are
different wait so change shoes Midway
through what was going on in the in the
opening footage when the shots go
through the door and ripping it open
yeah it looks like the individual is
wearing black shoes with with white
stripes okay on the right a white large
broad stroke later in the police body
camera footage the perpetrator is
wearing Vans with a thin white stripe
and flames on it so where did the shoes
come from backpack okay or they had they
had a bat they were carrying stuff I
don't know or they took someone's shoes
I mean you're at a school there's
probably a bunch of shoes in in caries
or whatever maybe
I'm not this is the problem you point
this out you're like oh that's
interesting and people are like
conspiracy theorists I didn't say
there's a conspiracy maybe stepping on
broken glass caused damage to the shoes
so she grabbed a pair of shoes from a
shoe cubby because it's a school and
there's a bunch of shoes in there who
knows I don't know well maybe they
should let us know too right well yeah
just it annoys me when people are like
it's a conspiracy theory if you post
that no it isn't it's just two different
images that look different you explain
it I don't care anyway let's read some
more
all right cold Deluxe production says
Man YouTube must be pissed at timcast
because their live stream which usually
shows up on my recommended side every
night would not show up and I had to
come to their channel to find it they
said something they didn't like Monday
yeah conspiracy theory that's probably
true well so the issue is YouTube
probably would love to put some
restrictions on us they probably do but
so many people choose to come to this
show every night the shadow Banning and
suppression doesn't work that well
there is you know that's not uh fake
news all right but that's why I'm
honorable because they'd be canceling me
and Don Jr every day I mean to be honest
with you and I watch your show on there
too because I know that I'm going to get
something even if you can't put it up or
you got to take it down because in good
conscious you try to to abide you know
by the world what not on if you put it
on Rumble it doesn't matter if it's me
it's you it's bongino it's
um you know any of them like you know
Russell Brand it's uh Glenn Greenwald
like there are a variety of opinions on
there and it's uncensored I I'm just
very against having been in corporate
media for a zillion years okay of what
they do now to censor everybody's
viewpoints and you have to watch
everything you say otherwise you're
going to be canceled try to destroy you
destroy your family you know click bait
fake articles about you create a whole
like hysteria it's it's sad because this
should be the marketplace of ideas we're
probably going to start simulcasting so
I think you should it's my strong
recommendation there's a lot of
challenges associated with it
um as to why we have not yet they're
both cultural political and
technological but we probably will just
because I I think you know
we might do what Crowder does apparently
Crowder will just mute YouTube if he
thinks it shows too spicy so people
watching on YouTube just get dead air
and then let YouTube explain to people
why they're getting dead air on their
favorite show
all right let's read some more we got
Callum dimick he says the daily wire
standard of don't give money to people
who hate to you give it to us instead
falls apart when they do Black Rifle
Coffee Company sponsorships I've been
very disappointed with them recently
well go to castbrew.com
they teed me up oh my God so we're
planning on doing who said that it we we
can't uh we we can't right now set up
the subscriptions because it's a
pre-order phase we are now at the
process where we're going to start uh
the roast on on the coffee so when you
order it it is being made fresh right
now for the first time that's pretty
cool once we establish the chain of
production then we're going to launch
the subscriptions so you can get you
know two bags of coffee delivered every
month easiest way to do it easiest way
that's how Black Rifle coffee does it
and ground coffee you were mentioning
earlier versus doing because most people
like don't have the Grinders whatever
but you'll I guess provide that later on
well we're gonna get whole being soon
right now right now the coffee's on
ground can I just make a special request
that are you gonna make some K-Cups and
stuff all right just saying yep
biodegradable I believe I believe so I'm
not entirely sure they might not be I
don't want to defend the Paris climate
change of course for the time being we
have the pre-orders will ship May around
May 5th
they are uh it's all coffee ground it's
ground coffee and then we are going to
be rolling out once the production is is
finally rolling the whole bean option
multiple new varieties right now we just
have the four to start the coffee shop
should be open in a couple months as
well which is really exciting hopefully
I mean these things take take time and
uh then once the coffee production is
rolling we're gonna set up subscriptions
and that's the most important thing
because you become a member at Casper
and then you'll get your coffee
delivered every month on time and then I
actually you know I'm trying to figure
out some kind of like coffee box kind of
deal where it's like you'll get you know
a sample well you'll get like other
things too there's a frothing thing yeah
Roberto Jr sticker who knows what's your
favorite you want to go with the light
roast right now you said well
you know I I I'm typically a dark roast
kind of person right but just because
it's rise with Roberto Jr breakfast
blend you're into it yeah because
Roberto Jr he's the best superstar
higher caffeine content and the lighter
room yes
Roberto Jr is a superstar so you have to
do you have to need the caffeine to do
like you know your like high energy Chef
every night yeah
all right oh also is there gonna be a
discount
I signed off for like a discount like a
promo code if people like sign up and
they you know subscribe to your coffee
on a monthly basis you get uh yes we're
planning on having it so that every
month if you're a member the cost of the
coffee reduces until it gets the point
where it's really really cheap then it's
free not free because you know someone's
got to grow the beans roast the beans
pack the beans socialism we're not for
that I mean economic collapse but the
the general idea is
if you know after like three months it's
ten percent off after six months it's 20
off and then it goes It goes way way
down so we're after that you're
rewarding the um you know like economic
like longevity and loyalty of your
consumer base yeah and I'm thinking like
after a year it goes way down right now
it's 15.99 per bag and then I think we
can get them even down to like eight
bucks a bag after like a year because it
it all adds up the more the more members
we sign up then the cheaper it is in the
long run because like you know how it
works with bulk like the more you sell
the the lower your price you can get it
down then you're just battling inflation
all the way down all the way down and
then if we have to raise because of
inflation then we do I think you should
like throw in like some like a coffee
cup or something like that or you can do
a little yes we have gift packages with
that we have a club like a bundle that
offers mugs and it's um louder with
Roberto bug club club mug I'm just
kidding we made those as a gag and it's
uh it's Roberto Jr Lang like Stephen
Crowder does but now people we have mugs
but I don't know if we'll actually do
that because I mean that mug Club is his
thing you know I mean all right let's
read some more Super chats Bradley Meyer
says the Nashville Shooter had another
Target in mind however after she did a
threat assessment she decided it was too
secure Democrats voted against securing
schools act and protect our children act
yep
that's right I heard there's like a
different building isn't that the case
it was a different building that she was
gonna yeah it was guard there was a
guard on duty so she could that's what I
was referencing earlier in the the
program and about the eight o'clock
that's crazy
all right let's grab some more because
the whole Hard Target versus soft target
all right this is from schlongathan
mcwinkletwat that is not real that's the
name did you yes did you see that the
restrict bill is not about banning Tick
Tock at all but is the Patriot Act for
the internet on steroids and math wow
both it gets louder
okay that wasn't me I think it was
actually someone else's nose yeah that
username could have been you I don't
know oh by the way yeah but it actually
does let them ban tickets check his VPN
yeah just lets them ban everything else
like vpns VPN which I do use
I don't have one yeah how many how many
like YouTubers would be out of work if
they could like advertise vpns to their
fans by the way literally oh I'm
receiving a correction what happened
apparently we do offer whole bean right
now okay God
well it's because the graphic just has
ground but oh I'm an idiot yes because
when you go to the website you can
select between either ground or whole
bean they're both available right now
for each blend yep excellent so you can
get oh I'm definitely ordering the rise
with Roberto Junior whole bean yeah I
like holding myself uh it holds the oils
you know and then when you finally get
that fresh oil when you break it maybe
you should have like a rise with a roto
like coffee little grinder thing too
just another you know smash those beans
up little little hand crank Grinders yes
yeah
I like it or a little Roberto face and
you you you break them up yourself all
right all right Bobble uh Bean Crusher
hello Roberto Jr merch we have a Roberto
Jr flag
he's he's a superstar man he's he's so
chill if you go out to chicken City when
he's out with the ladies he's really
nice and he just stands there and he's
looking at you and he Minds his own
business his dad Roberta was a dick he
attacked me once he jumped and kicked me
Roberto you can't make it was this
provoked no he was misgendered as a
child and I'm being serious we thought
he was a hen we got a bunch of hens and
it turned out one of the hens was a
rooster I heard it out there when I came
off I was like no really yeah I'm out
there I don't know if that's why he
lived grew up upset but Roberto get
those eggs oh yeah we have like 150
downstairs right now eggs were in a
serious shortage uh no not us we got too
many we need to get in the egg business
but I think because we hatched Roberto
Jr and raised him he's chill with people
so he looks at you and he's just like
that they're all right they bring me
food but let's let's get to the serious
news and read some Super Chat super
chats
all right uh what do we got here
Let's uh let's grab one of these
agamemnon's gym bag says Brett excited
for Friday with the non-evil Aiden if
you're not familiar check him out he's
like Luke but he talks about Bigfoot yes
uh the not definitely non-evil Aiden
yeah lore Lodge will be on pop culture
crisis with us on Friday it's gonna be a
lot of fun
all right Mr squeaky says we have armed
guards in Banks because we value money
but kids in schools
it's an interesting point well I agree
yeah man
that's actually one of those few times
where it's like
I avoid political discussions online at
all costs I'm not here I don't want to
debate with people on the internet you
don't actually in my opinion you don't
reach a lot of people that way because
most people if they're willing to if
they're willing to argue with you on the
internet they're already set in their
beliefs anyways very rarely I don't
remember the last time I heard somebody
say you have changed my mind about that
when you're in a one-on-one argument
maybe it happens that's a good point but
at some point I like for some reason it
was during evaldi I just I broke down
and I made some posts about it about the
like why are we not Army you know
putting security guards outside of
schools of all the things to to like
allow myself to get sucked into the
debate about and somebody's like a
friend of mine said like that was like
really important like my idea like it's
a good idea like they just want to ban
the guns they just imagine was mad at
you uh well just my friends like that
idea that your idea about it and voicing
it was abhorrent and well then a lot of
people friends yeah we're still friends
uh like I I'm willing to overlook a lot
of that stuff because I know a lot of it
it drives people nuts and they get blind
spots when it comes to difference of
opinion is okay and we can still have
our discussions and hopefully you can
reach them in that way but they're just
in their mind gun control getting rid of
Guns is the only answer and a lot of
people it's very hard to change their
mind about that because they have
utopian thinking because they're not
smart enough to understand that 3D
printed guns exist and they can't ban
them it's insane all right Raymond g
Stanley Jr says how about creating the
correct culture is the right response
more positivity less fear-mongering they
say to be inclusive but they hate us
others hate Christianity hate families
hate themselves
there's this new show on TLC it's called
like seeking brother husband and it's
about women who want second husbands and
then their husband's reaction to it and
I'm just like the family is being
destroyed yep well I mean yep
but like brother husband yeah so is that
what it is
sounds like it is that a feminist
movement reality TV has been slowly
destroying the culture far faster than
2016 in all of the culture or stuff far
faster there's a show called MILF Manor
or uh MILF Manor right now is maybe the
most hilariously bad show on television
you sound addicted to it uh we talked
about it on the show but I don't
recommend anyone going watching it or or
assuming that that is the way you want
to live your life what about my 1 000
pound life or whatever goes on there
well people are always going to have an
attraction to you know the Bazaar in in
the unnatural so yeah it's like a circus
Freak Show
all right let's see what we got here
we'll grab some more Super chats
Quantum strange Quark says if you could
supernaturally stop everyone in their
tracks and tell them one thing what
would be the most effective message to
snap people back to reality
if you could actually change their
wiring and say what
repeat if you could say anything to say
it on YouTube get off social media I
mean I'm about to think about it do it
but it's probably a very healthy thing
to do and when you think about it and
what goes on in there and just like the
spin it's like a dead Spin and a group
think and
craziness how the idea that they would
believe whatever you said or just that
they would be able to hear you because
if they were actually just let's just
simplify it because I don't understand
why it's so difficult yeah what could
you say to people to wake them up like
what what do people need to hear
you know to get away from the cult
sounds
to melt the beams on the World Trade
Centers
so well but I'm pretty sure people would
just look at you like you were crazy if
you said that I thought if I could just
change their wiring not have to explain
it just fix it that's what I would the
media is lying to you I think is the
absolute easiest one it's making them
believe in helping them understand that
it is absolutely true is the hard part I
think they're starting to come around
you know a lot of people what would you
say Tim uh what would I say to people I
would like
I I think the challenge is it's not so
much about a sentence or anything you
can say but I love this video by the
Lincoln project where they take uh
depends out of context to make it seem
like he didn't know where he was on 9
11. or actually a better example is
um the uh Shinzo Abe Trump moment where
they edited the video to make it seem
like Trump was dumping food into the koi
pond when in fact he was just following
the lead of Shinzo Abe that was his
great friend by the way Shinzo yes he
was very devastated when he died oh yeah
yeah he's such a great guy most of that
stuff is what wakes it wakes a person up
when they're actually looking to be like
when they're actually looking for
information right for me it was uh it
was all of the you know very fine people
speech and then actually going and
reading about what it is it's the MS-13
stuff talking about oh yeah yeah that
was like for me where I was like it was
such an abhorrent lie it was such a
stretching of what was being said that I
couldn't trust anything you know Brandon
Brandon strikes are the same thing yeah
that he was trying to prove someone else
wrong because Trump did the the hand
thing and he was like then he actually
watched a video and saw that Trump
wasn't mocking this guy over his
disability he does that for anybody and
everybody as a as a matter how bad that
is like that whole story and then you
see that Trump's done it like a thousand
times it's just they set him up I think
they said they set that up on purpose
and how do you go back the thing is how
do you go back once you're woken up to
that and a lot of people was at
sternovich like I wish you could throw
up the red pill sometimes like you you
wish you could right but how he's coming
back around too how do you go back after
you realize that if they're gonna lie
about this they're going to lie about
literally anything anything so you can't
trust them there's literally like jury
instructions about believability and
credibility of a witness and if you find
that someone has lied even one time in a
material fact or misrepresented Etc you
can disregard their testimony in its
entirety I.E a good example come back to
Phil and Michael Cohn but that's another
story all right Lilia uh Lillian Mae
Briggs says will the coffee shop have
truck parking so the coffee shop is in a
small town downtown space but there is a
large public parking lot just behind it
so it does have parking I believe for
anybody this is going to be like the new
friends with like the coffee shop and
people hang out and play guitar and sing
songs about cats I don't know about that
maybe it's three stories the first floor
is going to be General open to the
public coffee shop hangout there's a
mezzanine and that's going to be Ian's
Crystal Cove where it's going to be like
a chill hangout like put up a curtain
where it's kind of dark lava lamp since
yes crystals then the second floor is
going to be the hangout space with games
we're probably gonna have a small like a
skate shop section where you can buy
gear for your skates your scoots or your
blades or whatever you got and then
probably have like a pool table and
table game set up for the hangout by the
way kind of like here yes and then the
but public and the third floor is the
elite club where you have to be a member
of the Tim Cass elite club to go and
hang out and that's going to be like
fully stocked fridges all the food's
free like a social club you go up you
hang out like-minded people are there
they're playing video games they're
watching shows they're you know drinking
coffee like cured meats and things like
that I want to go to that floor it won't
be nearly as fancy so like you know New
York social clubs are like 50 000 a year
ours is going to be like 1 200 per year
because it's 100 bucks a month got it
but then we want to create a space where
we can we want to create some there's
value to those social clubs in New York
and a reason why people spend that money
because if you're somebody who works in
a magazine you spend that 50 Grand
you're all of a sudden hanging out with
a guy who works at a TV network and
you're like Hey we're doing a big ad
Camp it's a whole networking thing
exactly and it allows people to share
resources and become more powerful like
so how zero Bond exactly we got to
create something like that out here
substantially cheaper substantially
smaller but create that networking space
where people who are are trying to start
businesses work in the cultural space
can network with each other and so
that's the ultimate goal I think you
should tier it so that the people who
are like early adopters and they can get
in at a good you know rate Etc to try to
drive like that membership and then it
can go up I mean it's working places
right now people can sign up for the
Discord chat that's all we really have
but we're gonna do meetups so maybe
we're probably gonna do a meet up in
Austin when we're doing our live show so
if you're in the elite club it's going
to be like 20 people hanging out
somewhere super private
um but that's the idea we want to we
want to get people in on the community
in the culture building and create
something of value for them so it's like
you support us we have a special Club
where you can hang out and then we want
to create more and more benefits but uh
speaking of self-promotion Leland Taylor
says just listen to Bright Eyes For the
First Time and I gotta say wow as a
musician myself I am really impressed my
wife and kids were equally impressed my
wife had no idea you were a musician
this is the fourth song we've put out
you can purchase the song at
trashouserecords.com if all of you
listening right now do then we will we
will shatter the Billboard charts and
rank once again for the fourth time for
three of us you're a really good singer
I heard you just saying that acapella
deck downstairs and everything before
the show and I was looking I was like
because I was thinking that was on the
TV and it was you know playing but then
it was you singing while you were
playing pool yeah I think I was thinking
Soundgarden or something so they're so
good sounds good well I've been singing
porch by Pearl Jam like love it for 48
hours man keep doing it oh yeah but yeah
so admittedly so with this song we
didn't do as heavy a promotion with the
other ones because I want to see what
the organic pole is so far so with the
First with only ever wanted in genocide
the songs we put out we did a big
marketing push and we got like a million
plus hits in a week this song I've done
zero promotion on the YouTube video and
it's already got like 150 000 hits wow
that's what we want to see we want to
see the organic reach of a song with
zero promotion and that's that's
tremendous that's better than a lot of
musicians so not not trying to be a dick
or anything but I'm saying like we're
doing well with your support and I'm
hoping that we can get enough sales so
band camp banned us because they're
super woke which makes it harder for us
to chart I get it so but hopefully if
people go to trashous records.com and
purchase a song for 69 cents or whatever
they want to give we will uh hit the
Billboard Chart yeah I've got a question
for you yeah so um it's interesting
because you're obviously presenting with
a diversified portfolio Okay about a lot
of different interests that you're
somebody obviously that likes to
um you know challenge sort of the main
news media infrastructure by doing the
program that you guys are doing but you
also enjoy music so you're a musician
you love that entrepreneur because
you're doing the coffee and you want to
skateboard the restaurant all
skateboarder I saw you play with a
little skateboarder a little oh yeah I
got a Tech Deck right here that's cute
um and so I had to buy like 17 of those
for our kids I like it I'm safer than
the real thing me getting on it what's
your bliss you know when they say to you
like follow your bliss what you actually
like your true passion whether you know
some people are like artists musicians
but somebody loves to paint but they
like make furniture in order to support
their love of pain like how would you
characterize yourself or like your
listeners out there that are trying to
get to the to the essence the the core I
know you are I like complaining about
things yeah well that's fun for everyone
yes that's what I made a living out of
it so do little old ladies with blue
hair whatever we all love it and uh
I like solving problems I like
understanding how things work and then
trying to assess what the issue is that
people are having with it and fixing it
and so it's easy to complain about
things it's hard to fix but that's why
all of the money we make I should say
like a better way to phrase it is all of
our excess resources from this show are
going into producing cultural Endeavors
for the purpose of winning a culture War
because so few people in the culture War
are not making culture how are you going
to win it if you don't have any sure so
granted people are like Tim all you do
is make your own music and cast Castle
is just your own building and I'm like
well we're getting there we do have a
document around the Federal Reserve
which I believe is about to launch uh
Ben
story timing with the banking crisis
let's get this out exactly so uh we also
have Lauren Southern working on a
documentary about gun control a song
coming out with Adelita sway that I did
right so uh and we're we're doing the
coffee shop where I I just want the idea
what the coffee shop is we want to do
something called Saturday morning
cartoons sure Saturday Day morning
families come and bring their kids we're
going to have cartoons on the TVs
there's going to be like a breakfast
buffet or something the parents can hang
out with each other the kids can hang
out with each other the cartoons are
approved by the family so it's like not
where to awoke Disney stuff exactly and
so what we're creating is effectively a
like a a light version of Church
community Gathering it's not going to be
based around religion like church is but
for a lot of people who don't have that
it's a step in the right direction of
bringing people together once a week
Community yeah once a week in the
morning with their kids to learn real
values and share ideas with each other
and help organize that's what churches
were doing for so long and now that
people are losing that they've lost it
so we want to create something for
people who who don't have that I think
that's going to be go that's going to go
a long way and I'm hoping within a few
years we have like 50 different coffee
shop locations around the country that
do this and uh but we'll make money
doing it and we'll put that money back
into more culture and Community Building
would be good to replace as much Disney
as possible did you see that yeah 7 000
layoffs by April 3rd they're going
through right now that doesn't work they
laid off their meta division today as if
anybody cares about like a Disney
metaverse division that's doesn't that's
not doing anything how crazy is it all
right here's we're gonna do first just
to address I say I see um enlightened
fool says I missed the member chat
become a member at timcast.com and when
you do you get access to our members
chat which is in the Discord server
which is wholesome and academic and
Brilliant arguments as people sit in
their velvet robe smoking cord cob pipes
join timcast.com and join the Discord
server if you want that that uh that
chat and you can actually submit
questions for the call-in show which
we're going to be going to live in about
10 minutes so the uncensored portion of
the show will be up on the front page of
the website as I said in about 10
minutes so become a member smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show if you really do like it
they try to censor us and shut us down
but everybody's sharing it makes it very
difficult for them to do so you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally everywhere at
timcast Kimberly do you want to shout
anything out oh yeah I just want to say
if you could follow me I'd be really
appreciative I'm a really nice Irish
Puerto Rican girl from way back at
Kimberly Guilfoyle on Rumble and a shout
out from my sweetheart at Donald Trump
Juniors also on Rumble we love it we're
actually it's so freeing I feel like so
excited to just sort of Be You Know My
Own Boss get out there say what I want
um do the programs that I want without
any of this like you know hyper
management like critical you know
consensus group thing so it's cool and I
have to just say honestly I'm super
excited to be on this program and be
with you guys right on I want to address
I see Florida aerial media in the member
chat saying many of us watch on TV why
would we want to chat on Discord fear
not because we're actually going to be
rolling out our own chat app and the
timcast app coming out soon so you'll be
able to go on the app and actually chat
and that will be probably a whole lot
easier but also Brett uh I have
something I want to say before we go
Hollywood I saw your post about making
an X-Files reboot and I say no you are
not allowed to do that you cannot do
that and I will petition till the day I
die that you do not allow an X-Files
reboot to be made no go if you want to
follow me you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Brett dasvig pop culture
crisis is live Monday through Friday 3
P.M Eastern Standard Time right here on
YouTube uh a lot of this stuff is really
serious and we have a lot of fun in
there we talked a little bit about
politics as it connects to Hollywood
celebrities all that good stuff come
join us you guys follow me at Ian
Crossland anywhere on the internet
really you can find me and Kimberly I
want thanks again uh and remind people
Kim Guilfoyle on Twitter on Twitter and
everywhere else is at Kimberly Kimberly
Guilfoyle on Rumble is where you do your
show yeah Monday and Thursday at four
o'clock and thank you so much for the
kind inquiry yeah at four o'clock
Eastern yes it is excellent thanks so
much for coming thank you
search yeah that was a good one um find
me on Twitter or with me at surge.com uh
see you there we will see all of you in
about 10 minutes at timcast.com for the
members only uncensored thanks for
hanging out